- "Geeks Plus" is a YouTube channel now.
Our boss isn't definitely
holding us at a gunpoint.
- Help me.
- Please go check it out for
some amazing moments like this.
(grunting)
(heavy breathing)
- Guys, my mom won't give me dinner
unless you guys check it out
and by my mom, I mean
Meilyne off screen right now.
- They're withholding our paychecks
until you go and click on their channel.
(laughing)
- I haven't seen my girlfriend
in three days, please subscribe.
- I've been wearing the
same shirt for four weeks,
Meilyne won't buy me a new
one until you check it out.
- Go, go check the link in
the description, please,
go check it out.
- Check it out, please.
- Help.
(laughing)
- Someone's taking such a massive shit
that they've clogged up the top toilet.
- I took a shit downstairs. That ain't me.
- I think I took a shit
like two hours ago.
- You might have to sort that out later.
- It was not big, I won't
lie. I'm taking this to court.
(gentle music)
- What's up you zesty zymolytic zoologist,
welcome back to another episode,
- Zoologist?
- That's the only word starting
with, "Z" I could think of.
- There's like one out
there watching us right now.
- Yeah, he's like I'm Zesty, I'm Zymolytic
and I'm a zoologist, thank you Joey.
Welcome back to another
episode of Trash Taste.
I'm Joey with Garnt and Connor.
- I don't think I've ever met
a single zoologist yet, yet.
(Joey and Garnt laughing)
- They'll be the one comment.
- Now there's gonna be that
one comment being like-
- Zesty zymolytic zoologist here.
- I'm right here, I'm right here.
- Do I know a zoologist?
- I know a zoologist.
- Yeah, I do.
- I wouldn't be surprised
if you knew one,
- Why?
'cause I feel like in Australia there's
a lot more zoologist there because-
- Yeah, it's just next door
neighbor Ted, isn't it?
- Yeah, yeah, right?
Because there's just so much
more wildlife over there.
- Yeah, they're all there.
- Yeah, everyone needs to be a zoologist,
otherwise how do you know
what's gonna kill you there or not.
- Oh, you've never been Birmingham?
- Every time a snake pops up it's like,
"Someone call a zoologist."
And Ted is like, "Yeah, all
right let's have a look at this.
Yeah, you're right, you're
right, she'll be all right."
- I'd never met someone
who does stuff with zoos
that is sad.
- [Garnt] What do you mean?
- [Connor] People who work with animals-
- You've never met a depressed zoologist?
- People who like work with animals
are always like the most
chill, happiest people.
- To be fair I would be-
- They have the best customers.
- I would be pretty happy as well
if I could work with animals.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, when you hear about these,
like they're always in Australia like,
"Yeah, we work on the coast."
And they're just like, they
like help coral or some shit
and they're just always like
super happy, they're like,
"You wanna save the coral?"
- Well I mean, you know,
what kind of message
will they be presenting,
if they're like super sad?
- I want a miserable zoologist
- (deep sighing) Yeah, you know.
- who's like, "Turns out planet is dying,
it's fucking annoying, can't do it."
- Yeah, there's fucking kangaroos
living outta my backyard.
- I don't know I feel like
you're either like happy
that you're working with animals
that you like to be around, right?
- [Joey] Mmm.
'Cause you've chosen to
be in that profession-
- First choice.
- Or I mean like, the
only thing I can think of
is people who work with
like, venomous animals
or something like that
or animals that can put you in danger,
but if that's the case,
you have to be someone
who's enthusiastic enough-
- Yeah, they love it, they're like-
- They fucking love it, right?
- They're like, "Oh, don't
pet the crocodile too hard,
I'm gonna chuck it, I'm gonna jump on it."
- Yeah, it's like those videos
of like the, those like,
you know, venomous like
snakes and spider collectors,
they're just like every time they're like,
"All right, I just got
a brand new tarantula,
this thing could kill me in an instant,
but my God she's a beauty."
You know like, they're just like,
they're so happy to see this
like really a, to be fair,
a lot of venomous creatures
do look fucking cool.
- [Grant] Yeah.
- [Connor] Yeah.
- Would I wanna be around one though?
- [Connor] Does your life insurance-
- No.
- Does your life insurance cost up
if you own like a
venomous spider or snake?
- You might have to maybe
like double VAX actually,
you know, like double,
like double life insurance.
(laughing)
- I think you can vaccinate
these venomous things.
- Can I like double life insurance?
- I don't think that's how venom works.
- I'm pretty sure it's not.
(Garnt and Joey laughing)
I'm pretty sure you have to
wait until you get poisoned.
- Yeah, I think that there's
a snake with like COVID venom,
you know, like the newest str,
like the Delta strain
of like the Cobra venom.
- But wouldn't it be so
cool if like, you know,
anti-venom just like worked
like that or like, you know,
antidotes for venomous poison,
which is what would work.
- [Connor] Would you
really wanna sit there?
- I'm just like, yeah let me,
can I get the Cobra shot real quick?
- Even if you did, you wouldn't get it,
'cause like, why would you, why
would any normal person need
like 100 different fucking
snake infection, venom,
I don't fucking know.
We're not fucking Killua
from, "Hunter Hunter,"
- Well, you know.
- You don't need poison training.
- No, but like, what if you're
like going to like a specific
like area of the world that
has like a specific danger?
- Yeah, they do.
- Specific danger.
- If you go to like certain places
that have like really bad
mosquitoes or something,
if you get-
- Yeah, right?
- So why don't like people
who say like, you know,
decide like, oh, I wanna go
to the Australian Outback,
be like, all right just gimme-
- I don't think it's
that much of a concern.
- Well, yeah, you think,
- I feel like if more,
- until you hear about people dying.
- I feel like you have
more chance of getting hit
like by a car in the airport,
than you do from getting,
so I feel like we should
ban cars before we ban-
- With Sydney airport definitely
that place is a fucking mess.
- Just feels like the dumbest superpower
anyone could hope for.
- Yeah.
- It's just like that one guy
in like, "My Hero Academia"
who has quirks against
like every anti-venom
and he's only useful in Australia.
Like everywhere else in the
world, he's just useless.
- He's like born in the
UK, he's like, "Well, fuck?
I can't use this at all."
- [Ashley] Well, you can though,
it just takes fucking long time.
- Yeah, exactly.
- Yeah, yeah, I mean, you
can build up some resistances
to like, some venoms.
I dunno how much you
can build up resistance
because I dunno if there's
been any studies of like,
anyone who's like tried to
build up enough resistance
to like, take on like a back black Cobra
or something like that.
- Yeah.
- But I,
- Don't think you'd need to.
- Yeah.
I don't think you need to.
- It's like, you caused it.
You just get more used to it.
- Well, it's, it's like that.
- The more you get bitten,
the more resistant you become.
- I assume if there is
like, something that makes,
I don't know, like those ants
or something that like
make you really in pain.
Maybe if you just like.
- What ants specifi, like fire ant, like.
- A bunch of them.
- Like, like the bullet ant.
- What if you got bitten
by one every single day,
shortly after a while is,
you wouldn't phase you
after like 10 years, maybe
someone wants to try this.
- Well, no, because some experiment.
- We want to be bitten by a bullet ant
every day for the next 10 years?
- Isn't there.
that tribe that is like,
revolved around putting a glove
of bullet ants on your hands?
- Oh, yeah.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- But I think they do it
every day there. I think it's.
(laughing)
- I don't think, they don't do it.
- It's it's like a, it's like
Tim, where's my, where's my,
like my fire ant glove somewhere?
- "Honey, honey, honey,
it's trying to be a fire ant
glove." "Yes, dear. Ahh!"
- I'm pretty sure it's like,
a thing that they do during ceremonies.
- It's like to initiate
like a kid into chi,
into adulthood or something.
- [Garnt] Adulthood,
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- But like, from what I can understand,
like the people in the tribe
are more resistant to that
venom than other people who have tried it.
- Well, yeah. Obviously.
- Well, yeah.
So I mean, I dunno why they
like who, who decided that?
Who decided that they would
do that as a ceremony?
You know, let's just like,
get a bunch of fucking ants to sting you.
"You're a man now, boy."
- I wanna hear like the
council meeting of like,
when they decided that
they were like, "All right,
So, Jim's just turned 18,
you know, he's, he's, he's,
he's ready to bear children.
He's ready to be a dad.
- [Connor] Yeah.
- But we need like,
a ceremonious thing."
Some guy was like, "Maybe
just share a beer with him?"
It's like, "Yeah. That's kinda like,
what if we though, hear me out,
put his hands into a
fire ant nest?" Genius.
- I, part of me gets it.
I'm, I understand why.
- I mean, you know, I'm
not here to be like,
wow, your culture is,
- Why?
- 'Cause, think about it.
We, we look at the fuckin'
stars and we are like,
"Oh, well it turns out I'm I'm angry."
- So what, what, what
- You know, with,
- You, what, what, what do you mean?
- With like Star Signs and stuff?
You know, the only difference
is that we just agree.
- You talk about like astrology.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
- I'm joking, being like,
"Oh, I'm gonna get married
tomorrow, apparently."
- Oh, oh, oh, I thought I was just like,
I don't think angry is a Star Star.
- No, no, no.
No, you could be angry right?
From the Star Sign. Point is,
- Mad at Ares?
- I don't fucking know. I
don't keep up with this shit.
- All Ares are angry.
- Mercury's in retrograde,
I gotta put the fucking snake glove on.
- Yeah.
- Like I, you know,
they probably thought that
it had some meaning and it,
probably carries some value.
- [Joey] Of course,
- Like I'm sure, right,
Here's the thing.
We know that like jumping in a cold bath
or something is good for you.
- [Joey] Yes.
- We know that,
'cause of science.
- Like cold showers and stuff, right?
- [Connor] But before,
if there was no science backing this up
and you were like,
"Kind of jump in this bath for
sci, for, for health reasons,
I'd be like, fuck off.
I'm not jumping in a cold bath.
Why would I jump in a cold bath?
I'm not doing that. It's stupid.
- Yeah, I mean,
- Why would that help me?
- I wouldn't do it, even if I
knew there was health reasons.
- Right, right, but like, it's like,
you know, now that there is, right?
And so I can understand why
maybe these people have
this notion that like,
I'm sure, there might
even be health benefits
to getting bitten by ants, I don't know.
Maybe there is, we haven't,
we just haven't researched it.
- There's so many things
that haven't been researched.
We don't know.
I don't, I don't think this is
worth researching personally.
- It's like, what if I told you that?
Like, if you like, you
know, inflated your,
your big toe once a year, would
help with curing Alzheimer's
you'd probably be like, "Well
shit, I'm not gonna do that.
But thanks," you know what I mean?
(Joey laughing)
There's so many things
that can help, "X" disease,
or help stop things.
- [Joey] Right.
- You're like, I'm just,
I'm just not gonna do that.
When they're like, that one paper came out
that one time that was like,
"Research suggest eating no
more than five french fries
at a time to lower the risk of cancer."
It's like, let's be honest.
I'm never gonna eat less
than five French fries.
- (Joey giggling)
- That's just impractical.
I'm just not gonna do that.
- Go to McDonald's be like,
- I don't care.
- I think like at the end of the day,
people just don't care.
- No, they don't.
- Like if they couldn't
convince smokers to stop smoking
by like, actual scientific
research that prove
that it heavily increases
your chance to get cancer,
the more you smoke,
- Yeah.
- you know,
if they couldn't convince humanity
to stop smoking after that, then?
- There not stopping anyone.
- Then what would like, five french fries?
Like avoid fi, like eating
less than five French fries.
- Yeah, because like
the moment you're like,
"Yeah, you should probably
stop smoking 'cause you know,
it could give you every
type of lung cancer
or you know, just cancer in general."
Then they're just be like,
- Yeah.
- "Dude, that's kinda cool."
- I think.
- [Joey] And that's it.
- But as humans like, we're so shit
at recognizing long term effects
and by long term like,
more than like a week.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- Like something effect,
we just don't think it'll affect us.
- Yeah, because it's like,
"Oh it's a week away.
Anything could happen.
I can die tomorrow."
- We just ignore the fact that bad stuff
can happen to us by doing everything now.
- But, yet isn't it so weird
that there's such like,
a disposition between
people who are like that,
where they're like, "Oh,
it's happening in like,
three days from now.
That's basically never gonna happen."
To, to people who, you know, say,
believe in things like
astrology, where they're like,
"Oh, in 73 in years and four days time
I'm gonna get hit by a car. Well fuck,
I better stop preparing."
(laughing)
- Which astrology are you reading?
- You know like, like those kinds of like,
- Yeah, yeah.
- belief space,
like systems, right?
Like, you know, not to like, you know,
not to throw anyone's
belief system under the bus,
you can believe whatever
the fuck you want, right?
But like, that was one thing I
always had trouble, you know,
coming to terms with, with
that kind of stuff, right?
- [Connor] Yeah.
- Where it's like,
it's so up in the air,
that it really, and,
and it's not backed up
by science in any way,
as of right now that
it's like, you know, how,
why would you even think
about something like that?
Whereas like, with smoking,
for example, it's like,
"Well, yeah, I had like seven
of my fuckin', you know,
friends granddads die
because of lung cancer
probably due to smoking."
So you should, you know, if
that doesn't convince you.
- Yeah. I mean, I guess
it comes down to the point
where like, it's like even now science,
as sad as it is, science in
the, in this day and age,
isn't always like the determining factor
over whether people listen
to what science says
or not, because nowadays it's,
- 'cause science is the government, dude.
And you don't wanna trust
the government, do you?
- Well, I think science,
the problem is with science
and you know, the, this
age of like misinformation
and just not knowing one is,
a lot of misinformation out there,
- [Joey] Yep.
- and not knowing
which sources to trust.
And number two, science
has just got so advanced
that the normal person isn't gonna be able
to follow along with what science says,
because the logic is so past
what a normal person would
be able to understand
that you might as well be talking about
God or fuckin' stars in the sky.
'Cause like, you know,
how am I gonna understand
what the fuck scientist are researching
when it comes to like making
mini black holes in the sun,
like Institute or whatever,
(Joey laughing)
- like, and they're like,
fuckin' firing protons to each other.
Like what the fuck do I know about that?
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- You know, what I mean?
That's that's so far beyond
my knowledge of understanding.
- It just sounds like
science fiction, right?
- It literally sounds
like science fiction.
- Unfortunately, we're a
sucker for a good answer
and an easy solution.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- So that's
- So, especially when like,
you know, the top researchers
and scientists in the world are like,
you know, when explaining like,
oh, how does gravity work?
And they're just like, we don't know.
Then they're like, "Ha, I
told you, must be Jesus."
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- You know, like, just like,
because we hate it when
we don't know something.
- [Garnt] Mm hm.
- Like,
no matter how significant
or insignificant it is.
And so, when immediately
when we're thrown into
that kind of situation,
humans are just very good to being like,
"Oh, it's magic. Must be magic."
- A lot of the times we just
garner towards what feels right
- [Joey] Yeah.
- or what we want to believe.
You know, it's like, we like to believe
that we're all unbiased robots who only
go with pure facts and logic.
But a lot of the times we are very biased
towards our beliefs and it takes,
I guess, it takes a lot
more effort to unbelieve
and unlearn something than
it is to just, you know,
than it is to learn something fresh
or just like, build up your beliefs fresh.
- Well, I'm sure that happens in like,
between scientists as well, right?
Like, as much as you
think scientists are just,
like purely like facts
and logic based only no emotion
thrown into what's over,
I'm sure, you know,
there's been instances
where like, a scientist
or a, you know, let's
say like a physicist,
like, comes up and be like, "All right,
I've got this new theory.
- [Connor] Yeah.
- About how the universal was created.
What do you think?
- [Connor] Yeah.
- Here's, a bunch of theoretical
things that, you know,
we've been researching,
all that kind of stuff.
I'm sure there's been a couple
of scientists who are like,
"No."
- [Connor] Yeah.
- "That sounds dumb as fuck,
because I don't like you.
- Yeah.
- That, happens a lot, right?
And you know, a lot of
scientists are also religious.
- Yeah.
- Of them, you know,
'cause there's a lot of, "We
don't know a lot of things."
And also science isn't about
having concrete answers.
It's about attempting
and trying everything
and then proving that
there's no other way,
- Yeah.
- it could be
anything else, right?
I think that's the problem
is that a lot of people have this
rigid view of science is like,
it can only be, science is 100% right,
all the time.
And it's not, we're
just eliminating things
that we know for sure it isn't.
- Yeah.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- And so a lot of the time
when theories are presented
or hypotheses or whatever,
you know, we have so,
so many examples of
history being incorrect,
- [Joey] Yeah.
- and we fix it
when we realize it.
And the problem is,
is that a lot of the time,
that kind of gets
galvanized into being like,
"All right, well look,
science is wrong sometimes.
they get it wrong."
And it's like, no, when we never,
science is never ever
presented to know everything,
it's, we're building blocks.
- It's the most accurate representation
that we have at this current time.
- We're building up a
library of what we think to,
- I think like Tim Minchin
said it the best way.
He said like, "Science adjusts its views
based on what's observed."
- [Connor] Yeah.
- "And faith is the denial
of observation so that
belief can be preserved."
- [Connor] Yeah.
- And I'm like, that's pretty
much it because it's like sci,
yeah, as you said, like science
changes all the fuckin' time
because we don't know
everything in the world, right?
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- So it's like,
so we have to kind of make
compromises for what we now know,
which could completely
change what, you know,
like say like 500 years ago
when people legitimately
believed that like, the sun
rotates around the earth
and not the other way around.
And then when they discovered
that they were like,
"Well fuck, all these science,
what have all these scientists been doing
for the past 500 years wasting our time.
- Problem is, is that we are
really bad as like, humans
of understanding stuff we don't know.
- Yeah.
- You know, 'cause if
you'd have back then,
it would make total sense that we,
the sun revolves around us.
'Cause it looks like it does.
- Yeah, yeah.
- And we don't,
have any other way of even
remotely comprehending
that it couldn't revolve,
- [Joey] Yeah.
- around us.
But once you find out, it's
like, "Oh well of course,
of course it, of course
we revolve around it."
- [Joey] Yeah.
- "That makes so much sense."
So it's really easy to
believe in the thing
that your makes sense in your brain.
- That makes most like
logical sense in your brain.
'Cause like, yeah, like
I like I said before,
like science now has got to a point
where a lot of the more advanced concepts
where the normal person is not
gonna be able to comprehend.
- [Joey] Mmm.
- Yeah.
- And so at that point
you're gonna have your,
just putting your faith
in a person of authority,
that they're under thing is good enough
that they can, you know,
take what these studies say
and present that in a manner,
which you can understand.
But at the end of the day,
you're still putting a trust,
your trust into something
that you don't fully understand yourself.
Which, I mean getting back to the,
getting back to like, the habits
and the things you believed,
even if, you know, science
is like disproved it.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- Like, do you guys have like,
any like, wives tales
or like anything that,
any habits that was formed from
basically at a childhood age
where like, your parents said something,
- Oh yeah.
- And you like, you, did
it as a kid because you,
your mom or dad said so.
- Dude, I have a Japanese grandma.
They are nothing but wive's tales.
- Like okay, so like to this day,
like whenever I get ill, right?
I eat a shit ton of oranges.
Like I eat like a pack
of oranges, a day, right?
- I know a lot of people who do that.
- [Joey] Oranges!
- And like, because, when
I was young, my mom said,
"Oh, vitamin C is good
for the immune system."
- Where did this come from?
- I dunno where that came from.
I'm pretty sure there is
some science back to it,
but like, I think I've read to it once
and yes, vitamin C does
improve the immune system,
but that's like one, I believe, okay,
this is, all my memory,
so, you know, feel,
please fact check this.
- It also might have
just been Garnt's house.
- It might, it might have just
been my, household, but one,
I believe that's to like, prevent illness.
So, it like boosts your immune system.
So it's a more healthy immune system.
And two, there's only so much
vitamin C intake you can do.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- To really have a big effect
on your immune system.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- So, but like that
doesn't matter in my mind,
'Cause in my minds, I'm like,
I've been conditioned to think, "I am ill.
I need to eat a shit ton of oranges
to intake this vitamin C
to have these Fuckin'."
- Basically, just like a Pavlovian effect.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, right, right.
- It's like coughs once,
"Where are the oranges?"
That's so weird because
in my house it was,
if you were starting to
get sick or you were sick,
My mom and my grandma,
especially my grandma
would make me eat a shitload
of ginger and spring onion.
I dunno why.
It just seems like a
healthy alternative but,
- Yeah, yeah.
- Just one of those things
where it has that taste
to it that you're like,
this has to be healthy.
(laughing)
I don't know why, but this has to
- 'cause it tastes.
- No one else is gonna eat this.
- It tastes so harsh.
- It's 'cause it tastes like medicine.
- Like it tastes like
medicine before even like
being put in a dish, you know?
- Yeah, another one I had a lot was like,
if I got like a cut on
like my knee or something.
- [Connor] Yeah.
- Then you'd, my grandma would
tell me to put wasabi on it.
- What?
- What the fuck?
- That's a very famous
Japanese one, though.
A lot of,
- What?
- that's a very famous Japanese household,
- Where did that come from?
- I don't know, maybe it's
because like, you know,
you put like an antiseptic on, right?
And it starts to sting.
- [Connor] Yeah.
- But that means
it's like killing the bacteria, right?
- Yeah, yeah
- Ohh.
- So someone probably thought, "Well,
wasabi does that regularly."
- Is that where the stinging?
I don't think the stinging
is part of killing bacteria.
I think that's just like an effect.
- I don't know if that's
even a wive's tail, either.
But like I did, like when I
was little, like, you know,
I was running around in the park and
then I fuckin' slid and scratched my knee.
- [Connor] Yeah.
- And, and you know,
it was fine until I got home
and my grandma saw it, and was like,
"Oh fuck, we gotta patch you up dog."
So then she went into the kitchen.
I was like, "The bandages are over here."
She's like, "No, no,
no, no, no. I got this."
Pulls out a fuckin' tube of wasabi.
I was like, "Grandmother,
what are you doing?"
- Oh, no, no, no, no no.
- And she's just like, all
right, just hold still.
Like fuckin' pulls, you know,
squirts some onto a finger
and just starts like rubbing my knee.
- Ohhh.
- And uh, that shit hurts.
- No fuckin' shit.
- Like, a lot.
And you know, I wouldn't
exactly say it worked.
If anything, it just added
an extra step of, oh,
now it hurts and I have to shower.
To get this fuckin' burn.
- It burns now.
- And it burns.
my regular skin, that's
not affected by the cut.
- Awful, awful.
- So that, yeah, so, that was
the moment where I was like,
"Grandma, you should
probably like, you know,
read up on like some, you
know, basic first aid."
- I'm just wondering
where that started from.
'Cause like, I can imagine
it's something similar
to putting salt on a wound, right?
- [Joey] Yeah.
- Which is, you know, it's a,
it sterilizes the wounds
as well as it could do.
- Does it? I thought it was just painful.
- No, it does.
- I think it's,
- Could we Google this?
- This. I don't.
- [Ashley] By the way, wasabi
is somewhat antibacterial.
- Oh, okay.
Yeah. But if I pissed on your leg,
it'd be somewhat anti bacterial.
(Joey laughing)
The problem is, this is the problem.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- When you, when these
things get some form of like,
it's like, Yeah, you are 1%, right.
1%, right?
- [Joey] Yeah.
One right, I heard right, I heard right.
- I better add that to my
five minute daily life hacks.
- Yeah, is salt, like a,
kind of like an antiseptic.
- [Ashley] Supposedly, creates conditions
that make it difficult
for bacteria to grow.
- Supposedly.
- Probably written
by the same person who
said wasabi was it as well.
- Oh my God, actually this is,
- I thought salt in the wound was
you did that because you
wanted to like be painful.
Like you would like, torture to someone.
- What? what do you mean?
- What, do you think it's
like people in the painaline.
- That's what we say, salt on the wound.
'Cause it's like, right,
let's say I fucked you over,
to put salt in the wound,
I'll do it extra damage.
- It,
- Do it to fuck someone over.
- It is painful, but I'm pretty sure,
- Where did they originate
from, salt in the wound?
Can you Google this?
I'm pretty sure it's not meant,
it's not medical or anything.
It's like., it's to add
more pain to someone.
- I mean, I think it came from like,
salt is like a preserver, right?
So it kind of makes it
hard for bacteria to grow.
- No, no, no, no.
- It preserves the wound.
- This is complete bullshit,
you're making this up now.
- Guys, actually, I don't
know where I know this from,
but I,
- Yeah,
you're just making shit up.
- [Ashley] It didn't means
what you think it means.
- Yeah.
- [Ashley] It's(indistinct)
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Yeah, no, no ,no, no.
- It's no medical, "Step on a crack break
your mother's back."
No, that is not how that
works, it just rhymes.
You think that medical
things happen to exist
because they rhyme.
- I'm actually curious where okay,
Is it so, does putting salt in
a wound make it worse at all?
Does it do anything?
- [Ashley] Does make it hurt more.
- Yeah, I know.
- I know that, I know that.
I know that.
- [Ashley] Does make it hurt more.
But it's also like, you know,
it makes it difficult for
bacteria to grow, it does.
- It makes it difficult,
it's so vague though.
That's like, there's a
difference between a treatment
and something.
- Yeah,
just put some antiseptic on.
- Sure. If I cut my leg off,
it'd be harder for me to walk.
Like I, you know, it's,
- Put some salt.
- [Ashley] Yeah, that's why like you,
you wash wounds with like
saline solutions, as well.
Yeah, you don't do with salt.
- [Ashley] Saline solution.
- Yeah, but saline solution is salt water.
- Yeah, it's salt water, that's,
- You put like, you don't put on those,
like the fuckin' rocks
rubbing it in there.
- No we don't, that's not why.
- The saying isn't put saline on me.
- I cut my legs.
(laughing)
- All I'm saying is if I'm
like lost in the wilderness
or something and I'm like,
fuckin' like miles away
from Civilization.
- Put some rock salt on it.
- Yeah, just like grind up some rock salt
and just like just sprinkle
it on, sprinkle it on.
- Japan though, is full of
so many of those kinds of
idioms, it's like,
- We're not taking medical
advice from idioms and,
- Oh, no, no, no.
But like, there's a lot
of like idioms like that,
especially in Japan where
it's like, you know,
one of them that, my
grandma used to tell me
all the fuckin' time was
like, don't whistle at night
because snakes will come.
- [Connor] Yeah.
- And it wasn't until
a couple years later I
found out snakes are deaf,
so,
- [Connor] Yeah.
And then I started whistling
like a motherfucker
during the night time, you know?
So it's like, where did they come from?
I dunno.
- It's like I said, step on the crack,
- Break your mothers back.
- [Joey] Yeah.
Why? Okay, I, and as a kid, I even, I was,
when I'd heard this, I was like, no,
that doesn't make any sense.
- How fragile is my mother's back.
- I was like, I've stepped on many cracks.
Intentionally, after hearing this
to test the theory out.
Would, am I a bad person?
Probably.
- You go home, your mom's
like writhing on the ground.
- Oh no.
- [Joey] Oh no, mama!
- I think about how
everyone has collectively
stepped on a crack at some point.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- Isn't the earth just one big crack.
That's, it's just, it's
all one big tectonic plate.
- [Joey] Also, what does?
- All of Japan is a crack.
- Also? What defines as a crack?
Like if I were to step on an ass crack,
would I still break my mother's back or?
(laughing)
- I'm pretty sure.
- So I bend over for a second.
Ahh.
- Well, how, amazing, how this, you know,
scientific fact actually
just rhymes as well.
- [Joey] Yeah, wow.
- Amazing.
Also, but other stuff that
I don't really believe in,
anything like that.
And even as a kid, I remember
that whenever I heard these,
I was like, no, that doesn't sound right.
- Why? What?
- Like a cat crossing ,under
an going under a ladder.
- Oh yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Oh.
- Or a black cat crossing
your path is bad luck.
- I think that's more
like superstition though.
- That's a superstition.
- That's what do you is?
This is chugging a bunch of
oranges not superstition?
- I guess so, I guess so.
- It is.
They're all superstitions.
- I don't know, if.
- Wait what's the,
what's the difference?
- You just wanna go pee on it.
- What's the difference between
superstition and an idiom.
- Well, idioms are more
to explain, like it's.
- Like an example.
- Raining cats and dogs.
- Oh, I see, I see, I see, okay.
- That's an idiom, but,
- Oh yeah, so yeah, all of these, okay.
Replace idiom with superstitious.
- [Garnt] Superstitions.
- [Connor] Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- These are all superstitions.
- You know, I guess it's
superstitious of you
to consume bunch of oranges in the hope
that it'll cure your illness, right?
That's superstitious.
- I feel like
there's another word for it.
- You have no, no 'cause it's.
- Bullshit?
- No, cause it's purely
based on like hearsay
and information you've heard and stuff.
- But, but I feel like there's,
- [Ashley] These're all folk remedies.
- Yeah, It, I,
- It's all superstitious though, right?
That's what it originates from,
it's all underneath that, right?
- Alternative Medicine.
- I feel like it's come from
like someone's, experience
that has been passed down.
Superstition feels more
like supernatural, right?
Where you know, like,
opening up your umbrella
in indoors is good,
it's bad luck, I dunno
where that came from.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- But like, at least like,
- I don't do that anyway,
'cause why would you do that?
That's yeah, why are you opening indoors?
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Well, like what if you're
in like an umbrella store
and you wanna test it out, right?
- Yeah, they have umbrella stores?
- Yeah, in Japan.
- You never get to open it though, do you?
- Yeah, you do.
- Oh, wait yeah.
- Yeah, I mean it's,
- I'm cracking that bad boy open.
- I crack that bad boy.
- But that's, you know, come on
if were my own house, come on.
- And then every middle aged woman
in that store looked at
me like, "Superstition."
- I don't think they believe
in that, in Japan there.
- A lot of people do.
- [Connor] Do they really?
- Yeah, a lot of people do.
- I feel like in Asia,
the culture around
superposition is like very,
very prevalent,
- [Joey] Because every, everything is,
- They don't call it superstitious.
It has some kind of merit to it.
- Well, 'cause everything like, you know,
'cause the whole belief
system is very like,
spiritual based, all right?
- [Connor] Yeah.
- So I think a lot of superstitions
are more widely believed.
- There's like a, I'd say a scale of like,
- [Joey] Yeah.
- stepping on a crack
or break your mom's back.
- Yeah, that's like,
- The lower end of belief.
- [Joey] Well, yeah.
- Yeah. Whereas
maybe I've, heard this from many people,
the vitamin C thing.
- Yeah.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- Which I have, I dunno
if it has any merit,
I dunno if it does.
- I dunno, it just like,
there is some like really,
really basic logic around it,
that you're like, I can kind of see that.
- It's like saying like, it's like
I have this theory that drinking water
will help me feel better
and it's like, you are right.
But I feel like you are vastly like,
oversimplifying the situation.
- It's kind of like the
same thing with say,
you like your experience with
like, manuka, honey, right?
I'm just like,
- Yeah, that is superstitious.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, I'm just like,
is there any science behind that?
But like when I had, when
I had COVID I was like
fucking spooning these, this manuka honey,
like nobody's business.
- That's like a,
- It actually like, helped my throat.
Like,
- What's it called?
- It felt a lot better.
- What's it called? The placebo.
- [Joey] Placebo.
- It could be.
- That's like a placebo.
- Which is like,
I'd argue is a branch of
the superstitious crew.
- 'Cause, I actually remember,
- Placebo is the documented effect,
that it actually has an effect.
- Yes, yeah.
- As in,
your brain is making up,
- [Joey] Yeah.
for some form of fucking
thing that you think.
- But placebo's so interesting because,
- [Connor] Ahh, so,
- it's like, it hasn't been like,
properly studied and the scientists reckon
and like a lot of psychologists
reckon there is like,
something legitimate there,
- [Connor] Yeah.
- but we just dunno what it is.
- Because we don't, we don't
know what the fuck is happening
- Because it's like, we don't know
if it's actually a thing that works
or if it's just coincidence.
- [Connor] Yeah.
- Like,
- What?
- [Ashley] Well,
the placebo effect is, that is, does work.
We just don't know how.
- Yeah.
We, we dunno how it,
- it's document, it's like the whole,
remember the life flashing
before you're eyes thing?
- Yeah.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- And how I was telling you guys recently
there was an article that
said they were scanning
someone's brain on a table,
which is collecting scans.
We didn't talk about this on podcasts.
We talked about in the
taxi, I remember this.
- Oh yeah, that's right.
(laughing)
- I've gotta remember things.
I've got like a catalog of our
topics that we talked about.
Joey you mentioned the superstitious.
We'd mentioned that in the
episode before, I knew that,
but Joe didn't go on it for
too long, so I was like,
I won't say anything.
- [Joey] Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Anyway, the guy was getting
a scan, a brain scan, right?
- Right.
- And you know,
he's having a regular scan,
brain checking what's
going on in the brain.
Oh well what's going on there.
And during this generic
scan that they were doing,
the guy died of a heart attack.
And whilst they were scanning
him, while he was dying,
I assume they tried to help him.
I assume they didn't just leave him, like,
"Now hold on, let's keep scanning.
- Oh, well this data's lit.
- Hold off, hold off, hold off, the data.
They did find out that
apparently right before he died,
it was the part of his brain
that was responsible for
memories was like firing like crazy.
- Yeah.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- Which would, although not proven,
'cause it's only one instance.
It would back up the theory that,
- [All] Your life
flashed before your eyes.
- Or least all these
memories start flashing.
- Right.
- Yeah.
- Which is makes,
which is one of those things
where it's like, okay,
I guess that makes sense.
'Cause a lot of people have
said that it's happened
and although there's no
way to solidly prove it,
- [Joey] Well, yeah.
- but that's until then
it was not superstition.
- We only have, yeah,
we only have testimonies from people
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- [Connor] Yeah.
who have been like near death experience.
- [Connor] Yeah, right, right.
- Or like, you know,
- And then we have some
kind of not 100% proof,
but some evidence to indicate
that the theory holds more water.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, yeah.
- It's,
- We kill need to kill more people.
(laughing)
- Basically.
- Like right before they,
just like plug 'em out and just be like,
quick get on the CAT Scan.
- Right, now edge more people, I think.
(laughing)
- We need more human experimentation.
- You know, we need,
- Put an ultimate edge.
(laughing)
- What's that fucking movie?
- Is like, edging of life.
- What was that really shit movie
where they literally edged their life.
The whole, concept was,
- Oh that one was,
- "Flat lining?"
- "Flat lining."
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Fucking movie.
- Yeah.
- I never saw that one.
I, that just sounded
like a dumb horror movie,
- But no. like yeah, I mean like.
(moaning)
- I wake up and I just saw Jesus.
- This video is sponsored
by, "Raid Shadow Legends."
- These, you know,
gentlemen rage shadow legends is a,
"Free to Play, Mobile RPG game"
that has taken the world by storm.
I didn't know that Joey, tell me more.
- Well, I'll tell you more
because the game is available on PC
and mobile with over 600
champions to choose from.
Each with a unique history
in, "The World of Telaria."
Here, victory awaits
those who can rally the right champions.
- [Connor] These guys look really cool.
You can see just how much
each orc is influenced
by its tribe and
personality in each design.
Here's couple of my favorites, Kreela,
Witch-Arm is one of the best,
Allie Attacker Champions" in the game.
- [Joey] Damn.
Or this guy, Robar.
- Well boys, there's seriously
never been a better time to get started.
And if you use our link
or scan the QR code
on screen right now,
new players will get a free starter pack
worth almost $30 to kick start your games.
- $30.
And we are talking right,
we're talking the free champion Item,
200,000 silver, one XP boost,
one energy refill and
the one ancient chart.
So you can summon an awesome champion
as soon as you get in game.
- Ooh.
- You'll find these rewards here
in your inbox for the next 30 days, only.
- Back to the episode.
Going back to like the
salt thing and just,
- You're not, you're
not gonna let this go.
- No, because I, you just
like talking about it
just reminded me about the time
where I kind of got an ulcer, I believe.
And so, like you you've had
a mouth ulcer before, right?
- Yes.
- So, how do you deal with it?
- I put like ulcer cream on it.
- Okay, what do, what if
you don't have ulcer cream?
Like what did,
- I just don't, try not to touch it.
- Toothpaste?
- As much as I can.
- Toothpaste.
- I've heard toothpaste works.
- Is that a superstition?
- Again, could be bullshit,
could be bullshit.
- Okay? So like as a kid,
my mom was just like,
oh, just gargle salt water, or like, or.
- I believe that does have some,
because saline you're making,
- If it's an inside the mouth,
- You're making a saline solution.
- Yeah, yeah.
- It was like, I would, well,
- I would always either gargle
salt water or, or gargle a.
- Die's nuts?
Sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry.
- Damn it, I was gonna say that.
- Mouthwash, mouthwash, mouthwash.
- Sorry.
- All at once.
- I was, I was legitimately
right about to say
what you said that I was like, "Fuck."
- How do we go from salt
water to Die's nuts?
- We have a million people
who watch this podcast.
I'm so sorry, I'm so sorry.
- Yeah, I would either like gargle,
- We're a disgrace.
- salt water or mouthwash.
And then one day my ulcer was like,
so bad that the salt water
wasn't doing anything, right?
- [Joey] Yeah.
- So like, as like a teenager,
I'm just like, what if, instead
of just doing salt water,
which is basically just diluted salt,
what if I just go straight to the source
and just fucking pour salt on it, right?
(laughing)
And that, I swear to God,
that's, so that's what I did.
I just like got some like salts
and just poured it all
all over this ulcer.
And it fuckin', stang like
nobody's fuckin' business.
- [Joey] Right.
- It stang like,
it stang like fuckin' hell,
like burnt over in my mouth,
but then it kind of numbs the wound.
And I remember waking up the next day
and it was a lot less painful.
It started healing straight away.
Now, I dunno if there's
any science behind this,
I have Googled it.
And I know like some other
people do it as well,
but there's no, like,
I dunno if there's any
back science behind it.
But like, after that
I started putting salt
on my ulcer whenever I get a mouth ulcer.
And it seemed to like, it
seemed to heal it faster.
- I'm sure there is like, some
kind of science behind it,
- [Connor] Yeah.
- But like,
I feel that's like, probably
the more extreme method
of fixing, like you basically
just napalmed your mouth.
- Yeah so,
- Could though,
As the science says, you're
completely wrong, there.
- Yeah. Yeah.
So I remember one day.
- It could also just
be a coincidence that.
- I remember one day that, yeah,
one day Connor had just
coming in the office
and complaining about a mouth ulcer.
And I was like, I have
the perfect solution.
Just,
- Walks into the kitchen,
just comes back with salt,
- Just pour a bunch of salt on it.
It's it's easy, Connor.
I do it all the time, do it all the time.
I remember him coming in,
him coming in like the
next day or something.
And he was like, "Garnt, why did you,
you literally just convinced
me to pour salt in a wound.
That's all you done. Didn't help any."
- It didn't, I remember
it didn't help at all.
- [Joey] Really.
- It just like,
it stopped the pain for
like two hours in exchange
for like one burst of immense pain.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- But like,
it didn't do anything.
- You basically just poured your own pain.
- I think that Garnt
would've healed naturally
without the salt.
And I think he just poured salt
and happens to remember
that it then went away
as ulcer do go away.
- Basically, just did
like ulcers hardcore.
- The problem with illnesses.
- It doesn't hurt enough.
- Illnesses that go away.
- Yeah.
- Right, like, you know,
obviously in very serious illnesses,
the pseudoscience is very harmful.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- And very fucked up that people try
and sell solutions that
are like, you know,
they'll be like, "Just take our herbs and,
and your cancer will go away."
- [Joey] Yeah.
- Yeah.
- It's like, that's fucked up.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- You're even telling people that.
- Yes.
- But the, I think the reason
why with generic illnesses,
so many superstitions come about
is because they go anyway on their own.
And if you are doing shit
and it happens to go away,
you're probably, your mind is, "Aha,
I was sick one time and then I, I,
I played with my poop for
20 minutes in my hands.
Like Play-Doe and it
went away the next day."
And it's like, well, no, that's, that,
- Now I've got three other illnesses.
- Yeah.
( laughing)
I have, I have cholera,
but I did lose the flu.
So, you know, it's like,
you can do things, anything.
- Yeah.
- Do it every single time you get sick
with a generic illness
that will go away anyway
after 48 hours.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- And then you'll remember
that you did that thing
and then it went away.
- [Joey} Yeah.
- Yeah.
So this probably happened
with like the vitamin C.
You be maybe have a little
bit of placebo effect as well.
- Yeah.
- And then boom,
it goes away and you're like,
well it must be vitamin C
'cause every time I take vitamin C,
my cold goes as if you did nothing,
your vitamin C wouldn't go away,
- [Joey] Right.
- but it's not how it works.
It would go away anyway.
- But I want to like,
an experiment of like,
especially with the vitamin C thing,
of like catch a cold one time,
do the vitamin C thing and then
catch a call the second time
and don't do the vitamin C thing.
Which one heals faster?
- You'd need to do this
like a hundred times
to get any data worth considering.
- Well, there's plenty
of sick people today.
(laughing)
- But they're all different.
You'd need the same person over
and over it put their whole life.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, that's true.
- And even then, it wouldn't matter,
'cause we could just like
view the immune system anyway,
with the things that we do, we.
- I dedicated my whole life to see.
If oranges work during the flu.
Turns out, we don't know.
- Yeah.
- Science sucks,
'Cause science is boring as fuck.
It takes a long time and
people don't like that.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Whenever.
- Unfortunately, yeah.
- Maybe we can make it.
- They want results now.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, of course.
It's like, yeah, maybe we can,
go to another planet in 200 years.
It's like, "Oh shit, I'm not
gonna be around for that."
So what's the point?
- Yeah.
- Why do it?
- That's the problem back back
to humans are just so incapable
of like, really caring about things
that happen in like the
far future and like,
- Global warming.
- Yeah, global warming.
- The reason why we're so shit with it.
- It's not gonna affect me tomorrow.
So I was like, fuckin' whatever.
- Yeah, I mean like, I mean,
we've talked about
something similar before
where like talking about just imagining
five years in the future
or like where you're
going to be five years
or 10 years in the future, it's like,
- Could you imagine what
2027 is gonna be like, no.
- Yeah.
- 'Cause everyone thought in 2012,
that 2022 is like, "Yeah,
flying colors, right?"
- I couldn't imagine being
30 and here I am for 31,
like how the fuck did
that happen, you know?
- You basically dead.
- I'm basically dead.
- I think same with that exercise, right.
Like I can't, I know
exercise is good for me.
- Yeah.
- And I like it when I do it.
- But I just can't, I can't visualize
the benefits to my life.
- Exactly.
- That's the problem, right?
- That's why it's so hard to maintain.
- Yeah. That's why it's
so hard to keep it up.
Even though I feel amazing when I do it,
I normally have so much
energy, I feel great.
I know, and I can feel the
immediate tangible benefits.
- Yeah.
- But for some reason,
I just can't convince myself long term,
- [Joey] Yeah.
- that I can visualize that,
Hey, when I'm 70, maybe I'll
be a lot better off for it.
If I just put in the work now.
- Even, not even that,
it's just like, you know,
- 50, 60.
- Yeah, you could be
like working out, right.
And like a week later
you'd look down your body
and be like, why do I still
look exactly the same?
That yeah, that size as
well, dude, that hurts.
- Like it's, it blows.
- You get that pump on,
- Yeah.
- you do it, you go hard.
And you're like, "Why? Why?"
But then you eat like
two weeks of McDonald's
and you're like, "Wow,
nothing changed, amazing."
Which you love it.
You love that nothing changes.
But then you get angry
when it doesn't change.
- Exactly.
- We suck as humans.
- I know.
- Yeah.
- That's what sucks, right?
Is that if you want to
gain weight fast or look,
get ripped fast, you also
have to accept the fact
that maybe one binge drinking weekend,
may fuck your body to death.
- Speaking of human sucking,
I saw this recent thing.
- Okay.
- That.
- What a segue.
- I mean, because I looked
at this and I thought,
"Oh my God, human suck."
But there was an article that
came out not so long ago.
I'll just read the,
- By who? Who's the article first?
- There was a lot of different articles.
- Okay, okay.
- That came out
all over the place.
But I'll just read the
title of this article
'cause it explains everything.
- Go for it.
- Lonely Apers has just
launched a dating app
for NFT collectors.
- A dating app.
Somebody has developed a
dating app specifically,
for NFT bros to date NFT hoes.
- I don't, I think the
problem with this is is that,
- Everything.
- There is well, everything,
but let's now, let's I'm
gonna take a guess here.
- Okay.
- What do you reckon
the demographic of
people who have NFTs are?
- Okay, okay.
(laughing)
- Jojoesque dating app,
It's gonna work.
- No, no, no, no, no.
Let's let's look at this positively.
- Okay.
- Sure, okay.
- So what you are saying is
we are going to be removing people
with NFT profile pictures
from our dating pool.
- True, actually.
- I think, that's the a positive, right?
Surely, surely.
- But that means that we are just like,
forcing these kinds of
people to reproduce.
which is,
- Forcing, these people to reproduce.
- Are you saying people who like NFTs
should not be allowed to reproduce?
- No, I'm not saying that, but you know,
(laughing)
- [Connor] Is that what you're implying.
- [Garnt] No.
- Well it's okay though,
they go on the metaverse,
it's fine, let 'em have,
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- Just like, but just like
reading through this article
just made me have like, several aneurysms.
"There is no need to enter or
display personal information.
Instead one can link their
crypto wallet to access the app.
Once logged in the user
can display their net worth
and NFT portfolio,"
- It's awful.
- What?
- "You can also filter your matches
by their crypto currency
value and the NFT collection."
- What.
- I, if I had a dollar
for every time I saw an article about
something to do with NFTs that I despised.
I wouldn't need to buy
anything ever again.
- I was like, why did the?
- I'd probably own an NFT.
I'd be rich enough to own an NFT.
- I'd be very wealthy, I would be very,
they, I've not seen a single
good thing with an article.
It's never like, "NFT
owners pledge to stop,"
- Global warming.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- "To save the world."
- Yeah.
- And it's like, no,
it's like NFT owners
pledge to have a yacht club
where they all wank each
other off or something.
That's all, it ever is.
It's like the, the NFT restaurant thing.
It's like, it's are you just making a,
are you just trying to make
some kind of tangible effect,
that you own an NFT?
It's like, (growling) there's some reason,
there's some reason.
- Wait, so explain what
this restaurant is.
- You need to own an NFT
to go into the restaurant.
- Yeah.
(laughing)
- That's it.
- It's like, so,
- Do you just like, you
just go up to the bouncer
and you be like.
- I mean, it's getting to the point
where it's just like classism
with extra steps now,
actually it's not even
any extra step, it's just,
- Well we've hated on
NFTs, like so many times
I just, yeah, it sucks, it sucks.
- It's yeah, I just, I
just saw that article
and I'm like, I
legitimately thought it was
an Onion article, at first.
- [Connor] Yeah.
- 'Cause it sounds like one,
I realize, oh the sad
reality, that's a real thing.
- Even if they, you know,
they could turn around
and win people back onto and NFTs,
which I don't think they can.
- [Joey] No,
- I just can't see
them winning the public
faith back in it again now.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- Yeah.
- Since everyone has just seen
how much of a mess it's been.
I don't, you know, and whatever you think
about the technology or
whatever you think about
what it can be done with
it, you have to recognize
that the NFT like this kind of landscape
that it had has become right now.
- Yeah.
- Is such a mess.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- Rife with scams, fucked up shit.
- You know, money laundering.
Just every kind of awful
thing you can imagine.
- Yeah.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- It has had such a bad public rep
that it would not only need
to come up with something revolutionary,
that is actually good.
It would then have to
win people back over.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- By fixing its image,
which I don't think it can
'cause the internet doesn't
want to make it more regulated.
Doesn't wanna make it more fair.
- [Joey] It also just seems,
- They like how free it is.
- Yeah, it also just seems like
that community doesn't
really care about it either.
- No, they do, they do.
- [Joey] Do they?
- Yeah, 'cause they push it
onto everyone and everything.
- [Joey] Well then, how come they're not,
trying to do anything
to better their image?
- They're not.
- And instead.
Making these fucking
dating apps in restaurants.
- It's a free for all right now.
Every company and every person
is trying to grab a part
of like the, it's a gold rush.
- [Joey] Right.
- Everyone wants that bit of it.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- So the reason why
everyone is shoving it down,
everyone's throw, is 'cause
they have investments.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- They wanna make sure
they don't lose the money.
- [Joey] Okay.
- Pass it onto the next sucker
who comes in too late.
- Yeah, and it's like, it's also so weird.
Did you see the clip where it was like,
I think Jimmy Fallon?
- [Joey] Yeah.
- Like presenting his
NFT with Paris Hilton.
- like NFT?
- Yeah.
- Ahh.
- Of course, yeah.
Yeah. It's,
- Is it a meme at least?
Or is it like?
- No, no, no.
It is serious, okay.
So I believe it's Jimmy Fallon,
but they, Jimmy Fallon and Paris Hilton.
Well, Paris Hilton was on
the, "Jimmy Fallon Show"
and they started talking about NFTs
and how Paris Hilton
convinced Jimmy Fallon
to buy a, "Bored Ape NFT."
- What a nightmare scenario.
- It's so, it was so
weird 'cause it's like,
I've never seen a clip of two people
more out of touch with
like, the wider world.
So they like, so Jimmy finally brings out
his like Bored Ape, it's Bored Ape right?
That's the name?
- Yeah, a Bored Ape, yeah.
He brings out.
- Yeah, the monkey is,
- Yeah, Board Ape.
- He brings out his Bored Ape NFT, right?
- Oh my God.
- He goes, "Isn't this
beautiful, look at this.
(Joey giggling)
This is amazing."
And like you could hear
the audience clapping.
- I've seen this image,
I thought it was a meme.
- [Joey] Really?
- No, no, no, it is real.
- The image was put on
the picture to show it.
- Yeah, and I've never
heard such a applause
where it was so obvious
that there was a big light
saying, "Applause Please,"
because you could tell
the audience had no idea
what the fuck they were talking about.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- Another massive problem
with the whole NFT landscape, right?
Is that it benefits the
people who have big platforms.
- [Joey] Yes.
- Right.
If you have a big platform,
it's free money for you.
That's why people are doing this.
(coughing)
The moment something is advertised to you,
as you should buy it,
is the moment you it's too
late for you to make money.
- Yeah.
- You know,
the moment that consumers are
seeing big names promoting it,
it's too late to make money.
Yeah, some people might make money.
The majority of people
are not gonna make money.
- No.
- And the majority of
people are gonna lose money
and the people who get money
are people like Jimmy Fallon,
people like,
- People already rich.
- people who big influencers,
people who have the platform, the power.
- Yeah.
- To push people
towards their investment.
It's a glorified pyramid
scheme in many ways.
- [Joey] Right.
- Because it's like,
how do you get your money by
getting more people into it?
- Yeah.
- Right?
It's, that's how it works.
And that's why you're
seeing, like when I anything
or mentioned in anything NFT,
doesn't matter what the comment is.
These, these verified NFT accounts,
like everything with the phrase NFT in it.
- Right.
- They don't,
I could be saying NFT suck and
they can gargle on my nuts.
- Yeah.
- And someone
who supports NFT will like that comment
just because they've Googled
NFT and they like everything,
'cause they're trying to get followers.
- [Joey] Right.
- They're trying to get engagement.
- So then they can push
it more and have more,
a bigger sphere of influence.
- What if they just like gargling on nuts.
- They might gargle, they probably do.
- They probably do.
- They probably do, if they,
- [Joey] Like, "Yes, please."
- I hate it. I hate it so much.
'Cause, it's so obviously a scam,
like the moment that you
are being advertised to
about buying an investment is the moment
that you've already, you can't make money.
- [Joey] Yeah, and I think
that's what's so fuckin'
disappointing, as well.
Especially with, you know, as you said,
like big influencers, right?
- [Connor] Yeah.
- Like getting in on it,
like, you know, when I,
when I saw that like
"M and M" bought like,
an NFT of just what looks
like a monkey version
of himself, I was like,
why would you do that?
- Because,
- Very has my childhood died so quickly.
- The moment you have a
big sphere of influence,
it's just free money.
- [Joey] Exactly.
- And in their eyes,
it's low risk public image
because you are not asking your,
you don't have to,
it's not like you're bagging
your followers for money,
but what you're doing is making them pay
for something that makes
your thing more valuable.
- It's heavy incentivizing.
- Right, and you can claim just that you,
it was just an investment.
It's like buying a stock.
It's like, no it's not.
- It's like buying a house.
- It's not like buying a stock.
It's different, right.
There's rules around buying stock.
For reasons, right.
- Yeah.
- Even though sometimes
the rules are a bit fucked.
- Yeah.
- Still.
- Yeah. I mean, I.
- Feel very passionately about this
and I hate the system so much.
- Well, I'm like the only thing
I have to add to this is like,
do you think this negative
image is purely, you know,
is purely based on like the Western circle
and just like our
perception of the internet?
- Oh, definitely, yeah.
- Because like I've heard like
of the like NFTs have a very,
very different perception in
like the Japanese circles,
and, you know, the Japanese,
especially the art communities as well.
'Cause they see it as,
from what I've read,
at least they've, they have
a much more positive view
of NFTs and they see it
as like an opportunity
to of course give, you
know, ownership to artists
and stuff like that, which is a lot,
you know, given the
cultures, I understand why,
maybe Japanese people
would be more accepting
of this idea because it's
like for Japanese people
and Japanese artists, it's a
lot bigger problem than it is.
- I'm, I'm all for giving
rights to artists and whatnot.
But you know,
I feel there are other ways
that you can do it if the
systems were, you know,
probably implemented, not to
mention that in Japan like,
you know, the whole copyright laws
in Japan especially are just like
on the next level of outdated.
- Yeah, right?
- Right.
- Like it's so like I think
if anything, the reason why,
- Of course Japanese are gonna,
- Yeah, of course the Japanese
are gonna look at NFTs
and think like, oh, this is perfect.
Like this,
- Perfect.
- this gets around everything
that we've believed in
and done in like a really cool way
that supports artists like.
- Like more ways to copyright, shit.
- Yeah.
- Fuck yeah, bring it in.
bring it in
- Yes, please.
- That requires the good faith
of all parties involved though.
- Yeah.
- Like everyone has to
be using it correctly.
- Yeah.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- And the problem is, is that,
- They're not.
- In English, were definitely
not at least, you know,
and there is, there are
some very valid reasons
to own NFTs or Bitcoin
or any of these currencies, right?
Like if you live in a, if you are a,
like a Russian person right
now and all your money was in
the Ruple, yeah, you're fucked.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- Like your money's gone.
- You don't, you don't
own much money anymore.
If you had that all on a Bitcoin wallet.
Yeah, you'd still be very wealthy, right?
So that makes more,
that, in those scenarios,
it makes a lot of sense.
The problem is it's kind of replicated
what the fine art world was before
to like the big private investors, right?
It was basically fine art, it was the,
this glorified money laundering,
- Money laundering.
- And money transactioning thing, right?
- Yeah.
- And now in the West,
people figured out, "Huh,
you can make a lot of money
and money that you can hide very easily."
- [Joey] Yeah.
- By doing this NFT shit.
And so, it's kind of turned into
more of a democratized, fine art, shit.
- Yeah.
- For people, right?
Like the whole, you ever
watched like, "Tenant,"
did you watch, "Tenant?"
- Yeah, I watched, "Tenant."
- You know, like the art that
was held in the airports.
'Cause it couldn't be taxed.
That's actually a real thing.
- I know that's a real thing.
Was that a major part of, "Tenant?"
- That was a big plot
point in, "Tenant" is where
they steal the artwork
and all the valuable stuff
from the airport holding,
the tax haven in the airport.
- Clearly this movie really
made an impression on Garnt.
- I just remember things going backwards.
(laughing)
Like it's, like things looking cool.
- That's like the first time
in like media that I can recall
that has like told people
that these things exist.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- Yeah.
- People didn't know these existed before,
you know, it just,
- Was that an massive part of, "Tenant?"
I feel like I would've remembered that.
Which scene was this in?
Was this in the first scene?
I don't remember them ever.
- I don't fucking know
the full fucking playlist
of, "Tenant."
I dunno what fucking happened.
- I just like.
- They had a big,
there was a big plot point
about them doing a heist
in the first half of the movie.
- Was there?
- Oh my fuckin',
- The only thing I know is that the,
- 31s been run,
(laughing)
- He's basically dead.
- Oh my God.
- When he dies, like his life
doesn't flash before his eyes,
just, "Tenant" the movies.
- I remember them being in an airport,
but I don't remember
them, pulling in a heist.
- Why were they in the airport, Garnt?
Why they were in an airport?
Why they were in the airport?
- I remember them being an airport.
- That is a good question.
Maybe they were getting
a flight or something.
No, they were investigating
the, they were,
this is a complete
fuckin' tangent right now,
'cause we going into,
- Okay, okay, okay.
- they were investigating
the phenomenon, right?
That you know,
the phenomena where time
moves backwards or something.
That's that's all I remembered-ish.
- I can remember they're
stealing something,
that was in holding.
- Because I thought,
- And in the holding places,
they normally have art because
you can't basically buy
and sell in this area because it doesn't,
- Yeah, yeah.
- it's not under any
jurisdiction for the taxpayer.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Right.
- So you can.
- No, I remember there being,
I remember being paintings there.
I just don't know.
I just don't remember that being like
a massive part of the
plot point, but I over,
- It was like, I brought it up
'cause it was like the first
time it had been addressed
or brought up in like prominent media.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- Yeah, well,
- This is, these things exist.
- Yeah well, they've
existed for like a very,
very long time and it's
not just like fine arts,
but like, it's not just paintings,
any valuable thing, like,
- Stuff in the British museum.
- Yeah.
- That's only the place
where they come from,
you know like the point was is
that it's, I just think with the way
that NFTs are structured
right now, it's just, this is,
this was obviously gonna happen.
- Yeah.
- It was, it's just been rife with scams.
Like half this shit is awful.
Like yeah, there's some legitimate uses.
The technology seems somewhat
promising, right now.
- Yeah.
- Fact that it uses more
than like, most countries,
the entire like Bitcoin network
uses more electric teeth
than countries.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- Is very concerning.
- [Joey] Yes.
- And that there are more, you know,
they're making new coins,
they're making new ways
that are much more efficient than stuff.
Yeah, yeah, we get it.
But it's not there right now.
- Yeah.
- It's not doing that right now.
It's not working right now in a way
that works for the world.
- Do you think it would ever work out?
- Yeah, it definitely will at some point.
Obviously the idea of having a way
that you can 100% own something
digitally is going to be very
convenient at some point.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- It, the way you said yes, like, "Yeah."
- Yeah.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
(laughing)
- But right now it just doesn't,
the way that it's being
used is like a joke.
- No, no, I mean like it's weird to,
seeing how fast they just came from,
like basically nowhere to
everyone talking about them.
I mean, crypto, I,
- Well because, it has
been just been so, like,
it's just been shoved
down everyone's throat.
- Every celebrity is jumping on it.
- It was literally, yeah,
it was literally last year,
where I had not heard of the word
NFT till like May or April
and then I couldn't stop hearing it.
I was like, I remember being,
- I mean, I only found
out what it was like
a couple months ago.
- [Garnt] On the fucking podcast.
- On the podcast, yeah.
- Yeah, yeah.
- I'm so envious of you, Joey.
- 'Cause I think I just like,
yeah, I just avoided all that.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- I don't follow anyone who is in that.
- And now there's the
metaverse that's coming along,
which is just like, what?
- Well, have you seen that
these companies are buying like
space in like the metaverse.
They're buying like plots
of land in the metaverse.
- Yeah, yeah, I've seen that, yeah.
- So they're buying,
- What do you think of that?
What do you think of that?
- They're buying digital land.
- Yeah.
- Dude, that's like, I mean,
I feel like it is just,
That's some sci-fi territory.
- I feel like the past year
has opened up basically
the age of like the digital gold rush.
- Is this what it must
have felt like to see like
the .com bubble.
- I think so.
That's that's that's must have
been what it felt like where
you see millions of fucking
dollars being invested in,
- Like the dumbest shit.
- Yeah.
In like fucking kittens.com
or something like, I don't fuckin' know.
- Dude.
- And now kittens.com is worth millions.
- Right?
- I don't know if this is true,
but you're in the metaverse right?
They don't have legs.
Have you seen that?
- [Joey] No.
- They don't have, they only
have like torsos, upper body.
- So, this is very much
similar with me with NFTs.
I know nothing about the metaverse.
- So, do you know why.
- Sold off, online by Facebook?
- Yeah.
- Yeah, that's all I know. Do.
- You do you wanna take a guess?
Why they only have torsos in this world?
- Why.
- Is it for people who
perhaps are in wheelchairs
and stuff like that, or?
- That's a very noble thought, Joey.
- Yeah.
- Unfortunately it's not,
- Maybe inclusive of everyone.
- Can you fetch it, Ashley?
But to my understanding,
it was to stop people like,
doing like, implying sexual acts
and stuff and doing things.
From what I understand,
(laughing)
- Are you serious?
- from what I understand,
that is the reason why.
- I mean, it is like,
I read somewhere that like,
foot fetishes are like,
I think the most common
fetish in like the world.
- What's it got to do with Facebook?
- Well no, because the legs.
- Because of the legs.
- But, it's like digital feet.
It's like, "Ooh, ooh, those (indistinct)."
I was like, where you
going with this point?
(laughing)
- That's the weirdest tangent.
- Well no, I
- Joey just wants to
talk about foot fetishes.
- No, no, no, I was just like,
trying to back up your point.
- Like Mark Zuckerberg,
scared of Quinton Tarantino
or getting in the metaverse or something.
- I was trying to back up your point and
you guys made me out,
like I'm fuckin' weird.
Like he's in to digital feet.
- Joey's like, "Mmm,
them Sims feet though."
- [Joey] Delicious.
- Why didn't they just
delete the feet then?
If that's, just have no one,
- Stop.
- No one has feet
- Everyone's a stub.
Everyone just looks like Kirby,
you know, just stubs and knobs.
- [Ashley] Apparently,
it's a technical issue.
Like the cameras can't
capture the whole body.
- Bullshit.
- It's, I don't think so.
- Is anything questioned
about sexual stuff?
- [Ashley] I haven't found it.
- Can you Google sexual, Mark Zuckerberg,
metaverse, no legs, sex.
- Fetish, fetish, Mark
Zuckerberg, metaverse,
foot fetish.
- [Ashley] Also you can.
- What, sorry.
- [Ashley] Turn off face search.
- Yeah, it's on
- [Ashley] It's already off.
- So I apparently as well, there's like a,
you have like your own bubble,
people can't come into your space.
- Okay.
- But to me it's weird, right?
Because I dunno if I'm just like stupid,
but it just looks like really shit VRChat.
- That's what I saw.
And I was like, so is this like a game
that Facebook is developing?
Or like.
- It just looks like
VRChat, but just less fun.
And.
- Like VRChat has really good games in it.
Have you seen this?
- [Joey] No.
- [Garnt] No.
- [Connor] There's like games
in VRChat and it's nuts.
I was playing Super
Monkey Ball the other day.
- [Joey] Oh wow.
- [Garnt] In VRChat.
- [Connor] In VRChat.
- How were you not sick?
- I know, I'm gonna say,
and there was also like,
- I get sick playing regular.
- Like a Tron game where you throw discs
and they bounce around.
You gotta Dodge it.
- [Joey] That's pretty cool.
- Try to hit the other person.
- That just seems like
a VR game in a VR game.
- Yeah, so it is, and there's like,
there's a whole cooking game.
- Right.
- In a VR game and it's like free.
It's like, why the fuck
would any one party?
- How does VRChat work?
I never, 'cause I've never
played VRChat, but is it,
like kind of like an
open source kind of thing
where people can?
- Yeah.
- Where everyone creates?
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Their own games,
- Exactly.
- their own spaces and stuff like that.
- It's all user generated.
- Okay.
- And that's why it's so good.
- It's like MineCraft.
- Yeah, 'cause you'll be in
a lobby and yeah, does it,
is it annoying that you get in a lobby
and there's like 10 year olds screaming?
Yeah, that's annoying.
And think mark Zuckerberg
is trying to address
that by making it like age
only, like, I don't know,
over a certain age allowed to join.
- Right?
- [Joey] Yeah.
I'm sure people get the,
- It's still really good.
Like it's genuinely good, like I like it.
- So, okay, so going back to the whole,
like buying digital plots of land on meta.
- [Connor] Okay.
- Right, like how does that work?
Like what?
- I tend,
- It's more the question of why?
- Well, if you own,
- Advertising
- digital land, it's like the
metaverse is being marketed
as this place that is
kind of like, just a new
virtual reality world that
everyone's going to go to.
Right?
- [Joey] Right.
- So you can literally live
like a second life or even like,
you know, your online media
life in this virtual place,
that's called the metaverse.
So what are companies doing?
They literally buying plots
of land in this virtual land
for treating it like
they're buying real lands
that exists in the real world.
- Dude, this is just lame.
This is legitimately just lame.
- [Garnt] It is, it is.
- It's scary.
- [Connor] You want hear like,
the most depressing thing ever,
- [Joey] Please.
- What?
- Investors are playing,
paying millions for virtual
land in the metaverse.
And apparently a company
recently dropped $2.5 million
on a patch of land in Decentral land.
One of the most popular metaverse worlds.
(laughing)
- and the prices have gone up 400 to 500%
in the past few months.
- Wait, how much land are we talking?
Like how many digital square
meters are we talking?
- I don't fully understand it.
Another person spent 4.3 million
on a parcel of virtual land.
- Oh my God.
- I, oh my God, I,
- Is this what happens when
you just have too much money?
- Yes.
- I think this is what,
I think what's happening
is that a lot of companies
with a lot of money are like,
let's just throw something into it.
- [Joey] Yeah, your right.
- If it fails, doesn't matter
if it goes up tenfold big money.
- Right, right.
- I think that's what's going on.
And I think people in companies
are hearing whispers of it.
And I think I also,
I imagine as well that
Facebook is doing a really
good job at convincing these companies,
- Oh yeah.
- That, that this is gonna be a big deal.
- Yeah, sure.
- When I feel like anyone
who is in the tech space,
looks at metaverse and is like,
"I just don't see how
this can become a thing,
that's like good."
- Yeah.
- 'Cause how the fuck are
you gonna convince everyone
to get a virtual headset?
Do you know how annoying they are to?
I love my tech
and I gotta admit virtual
reality headsets are a pain
in the fucking ass..
- Yeah, absolutely.
- Well, it comes with the assumption
that virtual reality headsets
will be at one point more streamlined
than they already are,
which they really, really need to be.
'Cause like the barrier of entry
for our virtual headset is like fuckin',
- Oculus System has done great, obviously.
- Yeah.
- That is Facebook.
- And that is probably
the most user friendly headset.
- Yeah.
- But it's still like, it's not perfect.
- Not perfect, no, not at all.
- You like you don't
wanna have a business,
I do not wanna have a business meeting
with a fucking headset on.
- It's like honey, where's my headset?
Need to get into a business meeting.
- One of the main pictures
of like the metaverse
like you could have a
meeting with your coworkers.
Have you had a virtual reality headset on
for more than two hours?
- No.
- It is,
I have.
- I have.
- It's awful.
- It's, you get sweaty.
It's bulky.
- The only reason why
I haven't done a stream
on my Oculus is because
I can't wear that thing
for more than 20 minutes
without feeling sick.
- That's also another,
- It also depends on the game,
- Yeah.
Because I remember like,
I remember hearing about these rumors
that people get motion
sickness from where headsets.
And I,
- Superstitions.
- Superstitions,
and I'm just like,
- It's bullshit,
you're not sick.
- And I'm just like, they
must just be weak minded.
I ain't like that.
And I remember like the first
time I got like my Vow Vindex,
one of the first games I bought
was like Pavlov, I think.
- [Joey] Right.
- Or it was like the, it's like the,
basically a virtual reality CSGO.
- [Joey] Okay.
- Yeah.
- And I remember walking
in that for like 10 seconds
and I just got immediate
fuckin' motion sickliss
Like, my brain searched through like my,
the entire history of humanity
to like see if there was any
kind of experience that could like,
help regulate what I was going through.
And it was just like,
- [Joey] Yeah.
- Nope,
I don't know what's going on right now.
You're just gonna, you're just
gonna feel sick right now.
- [Joey] You're sick.
Like the thing is, I get motion sickness,
even if it's like not a very like,
movement intensive game.
Like I get sick after like
20 minutes of Beat Saber.
- [Connor] No.
- And like you're not
even moving in that game.
- Yeah, yeah. Yeah.
- I'm, I'm totally fine on
the Motion sickness part.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- I've only had one game
that's given me motion sickness.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- Or like, not even emotion,
like make me feel like, "Ooh."
- [Joey] yeah,
- It was like this ninja
game, Santiro or something.
- Yeah.
- And like, you jump around.
It's pretty sick.
But like you act, you jump in the air.
- Yeah.
- Really fucking high.
- You can change direction in the air
again in any direction.
- Oh.
- So you can imagine,
it's like jump up, fly
back and it's, yeah.
- I'm getting sick, just hearing it.
- But, it's good, but I,
the thing that I have difficulty with
is these headsets are not light.
- They are,
- They are uncomfortable to wear.
- [Joey] They're bulky, yeah.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- The index, I love the index.
Amazing quality.
- Gray piece of hardware.
- It is heavy, and also
the wires can suck my dick.
I hate the wires.
- Yeah.
- What I like about the
Oculus, there's no wires.
- Yeah, like the thing is
that I can't play a virtual
or I haven't been able to
play a virtual reality game
more than a few hours before either like,
my head gets tired or I
just want to chill out.
And I just wanna like,
'cause like I start sweating
a lot because you're wearing,
- I sweat a lot as well.
- Yeah, yeah, you, you start like,
I mean like you're basically
wearing a sink on your head.
You know?
(laughing)
- You're, you are.
- That's that's basically
what it is, right?
- Pretty much, yeah.
- It's like an entire bottle of this.
- Yeah.
- Traps the heat.
- It's just uncomfortable.
It's it's not comfortable at all.
And like, I don't think,
I dunno if this is just
like boomer me talking,
but I can't see it being a real substitute
for just face to face interactions,
- [Joey] Yeah.
- to me at least
- Never, no it won't.
- I mean like, you know, again,
like in order for the metaverse
thing to really pop off,
it needs to be like, VR headsets
need to be common enough
in every household as much as like say,
a computer is today, right?
And I just don't see it
happening for a while.
- The Oculus isn't, it isn't quite there.
And it's also expensive.
- [Joey] It is.
- You strap on these,
I think the Oculus is 300 bucks retail.
- Yeah, yeah.
- And yeah, that's steep
for a lot of people.
- Yeah.
- I think, you know, if you look
at the progress we've made in the past,
what 10 years, when did
the HTC Vive come out?
That was the first big one, wasn't it?
the first big deal?
- Yeah.
- When was that?
When did the HTC Vive
get released, Ashley?
Can you have a look?
- [Ashley] HTC what?
- Vive.
- HTC Vive.
- I thought it was the Oculus
Rift was the first like,
real big one.
That's the first one I heard about.
- Was that like the one
that was with steam?
- Yes, that was, that was.
- When did the Oculus Rift then come out.
- That was like the,
the OG Oculus Rift that was before,
- Facebook bought them, right?
- Facebook bought them out.
- Yeah.
- [Ashley] The Steam Vive
was unveiled in March, 2015.
- Okay, what about the Oculus Rift.
- Oculus Rift?
- The original or yeah,
the original OK.
- The original Oculus Rift was the one
with the rollercoaster sim.
- Yeah. Yeah.
- I thought the HTC Vive was
the first time VR headsets
became like, somewhat viable.
- [Joey] Oh, like a thing?
- Like to play games like, seriously.
- [Ashley] Oculus was March, 2016.
- Oh, okay.
- So, the Vive came out before.
- The Vive was the, I dunno,
I could be totally wrong.
I don't you could Google
what the first VR headset is.
I think it's fair to say at least,
to my memory at least
that I think the HTC Vive
was the first headset
that came out that like made gaming
seem like it made sense.
- Yeah.
- [Joey] Right.
- On a, it wasn't just a gimmick.
it was like, you could
actually play games.
Like SuperHot was amazing.
Some of the demos are really good.
And there were games coming out here
and there that were, that
were pretty good as well.
- Yeah.
- Now, I, you know,
I think we thought there
was gonna be a big boom,
but it, there really hasn't been,
- It's just,
- That many games in the past seven years.
It's just because the money
isn't there right now,
because it's so hard.
There's so many barriers of entry
for buying like a VR game.
So like the only big game I
can think of is Half-life.
That's the only like, game where
I look at this VR game and,
- It make sense.
- and it's like stands
up as like a game game.
You know, it's like a lot
of games that I play on VR.
It seems like a tech demo with like,
- Yeah, yeah.
- it seems like a glorified tech demo,
but like Half-life
actually feels like a game.
And that's because, you know,
Valve, like invested in it.
And I don't even like,
I can't believe they
made profit on it at all.
- Yeah.
- Like, because
I feel like that was more of
just them flexing to be like,
guys, we still make game.
Remember, remember, remember?
We made games.
We were fucking, we were a fucking amazing
game developer back in the day.
- [Joey] Well I play,
- We can still do it.
- Yeah.
- We can still do, baby.
- We still got it, baby.
- I played a lot of games on the VR
and Superhot is still
probably the best one.
- Yeah, Superhot is the best one..
- That's the game that I get
when people come to my house and
I'm like, you wanna wanna try, VR?
- Yeah.
- Super hot is the game
that, I'm yeah, try this.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- 'Cause it's so good.
- Yeah.
- It's so good.
- It's Superhot and Beat Saber,
- Yeah.
- which is the best VR
experience, I've probably had
- Yes, same here.
- So far.
- It's, I understand 'cause
like, setting up the Valve Index
is like, it's the best headset, right?
If you want performance and gaming.
But, my God..
- But like I think.
- The cable,
- It is a fucking commitment,
- I think,
- to set that thing up.
And you nee a space big enough.
- Yeah.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- Which is another reason why it like,
in Japan is like not popular at all.
- [Joey] No.
- Yeah, I think my problem with VR gaming
that I've had so far is
that it turns gaming for like, for me,
gaming is like a passive activity.
- Mm.
- [Joey] Mm.
- But VR gaming is
definitely an active activity
for me, where I, you know,
you feel physically involved.
It doesn't feel passive,
- I do like that, though.
- I do like that as well.
But like the, you know,
when you have like a fucking eight hour,
10 hour gaming session,
I don't want to, that that's like,
- Right, right, right.
- I there's only so long I can have,
I can do something active.
- Right.
- For that period of time.
Like to me, a lot of games
are a passive activity
where you sit down on the couch
or sit at your PC, you
just like chill there.
And you just.
- I think it also depends on like,
the demographic as well, right?
Like, 'cause I'm sure like, you know,
the average 10 year old has
a lot more fuckin' energy
to move around for eight to 10 hours.
- [Connor] Well, yeah.
- Versus like, you know,
someone who's in like their 40s.
- When I played a Gorilla Tag.
- Yeah, on, VR?
- On VR, just all like 10 year olds.
- Yeah.
- It was all 10 year olds.
- Well like, you know, I
think back to like when I was,
I think back to when I
was 10 and the fuckin',
you remember the EyeToy?
- [Connor] Oh, my God.
- The camera.
- For PS2.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Like when that shit came out
and you had to like
physically move around and,
like you know that like as a 10 year old,
that's like, fuck yeah, I
could do this for hours.
- [Connor] Yeah,
- If you got me an EyeToy
now probably be like an hour
and a half and I'm done.
- Yeah, but that to me, that
was always like a gimmick,
you know, like that
one time you go to like
your cousin's house and
they pull out the DDR mat
and you're like, oh, okay.
We're having a DDR night.
- Pull out the virtual boy.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Right, right.
- It's like the shit mat
that like barely registered.
(laughing)
It's like, yeah.
- You got a fuckin' stamp on like,
- Yeah, yeah yeah.
- You got pieces of foam.
- And they were like break
after like one use or something.
- It's a shame.
'Cause I think that like VR
gaming is some of the most fun
and rewarding gaming out
there when it's done right.
- Yeah, it is.
- Problem is there's no incentive
for people to develop games for it.
Like it's hard.
- Yeah, yeah.
- And also it's like, you know
when you're a kid and you,
I dunno if you've ever had them,
I dunno what they're called in Australia.
But in the UK, the brand
calls like scale electrics.
It's like the, you know, those cars,
you have to lay out that track.
- Yeah.
- And then you have the.
- Oh, hot wheels.
- Maybe hot wheels,
- Kind of like hot wheels.
- You lay out the track
and then you have those things that
like, you turn the buttons
and they go sroom, around the the fuckin'
what are they called in? What's
the generic name for them?
- [Ashley] I think you're right.
- Scale electrics on
like the fuckin' scales.
- I always thought scale
electrics was a brand
like Hot Wheels.
- Yeah, yeah, I think it was a brand.
I'm trying to know whether the,
- I only really play with Hot Wheels.
- Oh I, what was your point?
- It's like that.
That's what VR feels like right now.
And it needs to get to the point where,
current gaming is, where it feels like,
"Oh, you put on the headset
and you're good to go.
- [Joey] Right.
- Right now it's like,
I have to turn on the two base stations.
I have to make sure all
the cables are plugged in.
"Oh, I gotta install this update.
Oh the tracking's off.
I gotta fix the tracking."
It's like, it's such a,
it's like going back to that feeling
as a kid where you set up
that track, you set it all up.
Just for that like 30
minutes of enjoyment.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- Yeah.
- And then you gotta
put it all away again.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- Yeah.
- So like until it gets to the point
where it doesn't feel
like a slog to set up.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- It's not that it's active.
I think it's like a pain in the ass
to set up, and I,
- Oh, it is.
- I've got mine set up now to the point
where it's as painless as possible
and it's still a pain in the ass.
- Yeah.
- [Joey] Yeah.
Like I five minutes of
me turning everything on
and doing it all, is just
a little bit annoying
for my lazy gamer of brain
to want to do it well.
- Well, because you're so used to just
the turn on immediately start.
- Yeah, right.
- That makes sense, yeah.
- [Ashley] It's called
Scalextric that's the brand of.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Is there a generic name
for that kind of product or?
- [Ashley] I think was
- just motorized cars.
- Yeah.
- Just like the, yeah.
'Cause you know how, like as a kid,
I think we had a really dodgy one
and it was just a whole
event setting it up.
- [Joey] Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- It took so long, but.
- Yeah, but like you,
as I remember as a kid,
you had way more patience, you know,
- Exactly what I'm saying.
- like not even as a kid,
but as a teenager as well, you know?
- Right, right, right.
- Like, you know, I tell
people about the fuckin'
efforts I had to go through to
even just fuckin' watch anime,
- [Joey] Right.
- or play some visual novels.
And you had to like download
like 7 million zip files,
(laughing)
three tutorials about how
to like, install this game.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- And I'm, I think back to that now.
And I'm just like, man, imagine like,
imagine trying to do that now?
Where you can just press
one button on Steam to like
play a lot of these like
Japanese underground games
and all that.
- Well, even like console games, right?
Like you had to like
go into the bin to look
for the cartridge of the game
and then you had to fuckin' put it in.
"Oh, it's not working," pull it out,
blow on it a little bit.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- Put it back in, turn
on, wait for it to load.
Now you just fuckin' turn on your switch.
And the downloaded game is right there.
- Yeah.
- But like, I saw,
- I mean, I have all my games cartridge.
- Yeah.
- Oh really?
- Yeah, 'cause I give them to my like,
other people when I'm done with them.
- Oh, Okay.
- Okay.
- That makes sense.
- But like a big thing
that I've kind of like
felt recently is that like,
I've kind of like thought
what is the direction
that gaming is going to go, right?
What, because I've
recently procured myself
a PlayStation 5.
I know.
- [Joey] Oh really?
- I know guys, I know, I know.
- Oh, you're the lucky few.
- Yeah, the lucky few.
And the reason I did that was entirely
because I was like, I'm not gonna,
I don't need a PS5, I don't need a PS5.
And then Horizon Forbidden West came out
and Horizon Zero Dawn were like
one of my favorite games of all time.
So I'm like, "All right,
this kind of deserved
the special treatment."
- [Joey] Right.
- I'll try and go out my way
to get a PS5 in order to play this game.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- And the game looks fucking amazing,
- and it's fantastic, right?
- Yeah.
- But is it that different
from playing it on a PS4?
I wouldn't really say so.
You know, I,
- I feel like hyper-realism in video games
has almost reached a limit.
To the point where it's like,
- [Connor] Yeah.
- we can't get any better graphics.
- Things don't look that much different.
- Yeah.
- Than like eight years ago.
- They don't, they haven't,
- Can't get any better than this.
- Like I remember jumping from like,
I remember the first time I got my N64
and I played Super Mario 64
and like my mind fuckin' blew.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- It was like, I was,
I like running around in 3d
after 2d Mario all this time.
Like I could not comprehend,
- [Joey] Yeah.
- How such an experience Could be done.
- 12 Year old me was
like, "Up is forward?"
- [Garnt] Yeah, right?
(heavy panting)
- What, how does that work?
(laughing)
- And now I'm just like,
I think there are extra pixels that I'm,
that my eye is seeing right now.
- Right.
- I feel like,
- Unless you have like a 12K like TV,
- [Garnt] Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- You're not gonna see the difference.
- Right.
- Yeah.
- I feel like it's a bit smoother
'cause there are slightly more frames,
but it certainly isn't
like the mind blown,
- Yeah.
- kind of experience that I felt before.
- But that's what I'm saying like that,
that's why I feel like
we've almost reached
that limit when it comes to like,
amazing graphically how games can be.
And that's why I feel like,
especially the Indie
scene for the past like,
10 years has been more focused on
and making these more like stylized games,
like pixel games and stuff like that.
Like yeah, you know what I want back?
I want cell shading in games back.
Can we have that back?
- Has it ever left?
- I think it's like it used
to be in the forefront.
I feel, of like all the mainline games
or like the main.
- [Connor] Is it?
- In a way it was,
- I don't think so.
I think for like certain
demographics, like, you know,
like when like Wind Waker
came out, for example,
everyone fuckin' hated it
at first until they played
and they realized how
amazing it was, right?
- I remember when everyone,
when Wind Waker came out
and there was so much discussions in like
magazines to be like, this is a step down,
(Joey giggling)
like this is a graphical step down.
- That's what the trend was, right?
It was realism, realism, realism.
- Yeah, realism, realism.
And then when we started getting used
to the cell shaded shit,
like with what's it?
Lollipop Chainsaw is like
another game series that's like
very cell shade, very stylized, right?
- Yeah.
- People are also like, oh man,
this game looks too fucking weird.
Like it's not pretty enough.
And then people immediately,
when they played the game,
they found out, oh, you know what?
This is pretty, but just on a
different caliber of pretty.
- Yeah. I mean like I would say like
Wind Waker has aged the best
visually in terms of like,
I would argue like pretty
much every Zelda game.
- Yeah.
- You know? I mean,
I think it looks better
than Pokemon Arceus.
- And the best thing is,
- Right?
- Yeah, exactly.
And the best thing is
those kinds of styles,
a lot of the times are ageless.
- Yeah, like look at Cuphead.
- Yeah, or, yeah, exactly.
Or like, you know,
like Wind Waker looks just as good
even in today's standards
because it's so stylized.
Whereas if you go back to like,
you know, Ocarina of Time, right?
You're like, ooh,
not as pretty as my 12
year old mind back then.
- Ocarina of Time, was a fugly game.
- Yeah.
- It's not a pretty game,
- If you have the context, you know,
the setting and stuff
it makes perfect sense.
- Of course, you know, people
who say like, you know,
with all those N64 games who
are like, "No, no, it looks,
it looks just as good today."
Are obviously, they're just
operating off nostalgia.
- Yeah.
- Right.
But like anyone can look at
Mario 64 and go, "Fuck me,
that's an ugly game."
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- You know?
- Yeah, it just,
- Actually I think Mario
64 looks kind of good.
- You think, compared to like, Ocarina?
- Well , yeah like if you look
at something like GoldenEye.
GoldenEye looks awful.
- Oh, that looks awful.
- [Connor] Yeah, GoldenEye looks jacked.
- And you know, and Ocarina
of Time, I think looks awful.
I think Mario 64, like I don't know why.
I think it looks okay.
I don't think it aged as
bad as you might think.
- I think you should probably
take a little closer look at it.
- I have, I have, I have.
- 'Cause I was,
- Bowzer looks like shit.
Okay.
- Yeah.
- I'll give you that,
Bowzer looks like shit.
- The Peach in the opening
scene, I'm just like, Ugh.
What is that?
- That is true, actually.
I, 'cause when I, when
I think of Mario 64,
for some reason I go to Mario Sunshine.
- Yeah.
- Because that was like, I
guess my childhood Mario.
- [Joey] Yeah, yeah, yeah
- I remember, and Mario Sunshine has aged
a lot better visually than Mario 64.
- A million times better, yeah.
- Yeah, because with, yeah,
I feel like that generation of games like,
- PS1?
- No, not,
I wouldn't say PS1, 'cause like,
I look back at like Metal Gear Solid one
and I look back at like,
pixels talking to each other,
like Snake's face, he doesn't
have detail, it's like.
- One triangle.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- It's just a triangle.
And I remember thinking,
how the fuck did I get invested
in these cutscenes of the Snake
going, "Otacon" and it's just
like a pixel going, you know?
(laughing)
- But like I feel like
the PS2, GameCube era
was kind of when we started
really, like really getting to,
the point where I couldn't see
that much of a big jump
in graphical fidelity.
- [Joey] Yeah, yeah.
- And then afterwards
I did see a difference with PS3.
PS3 to me is when it kind of like peeked,
you know, where, you know,
Last of Us originally came
out on the PS3, right?
- Yes.
- And I was just like,
I, to me it like the original Last of Us,
like pretty much every game looks about
the same as Last of Us, you know?
- Yeah.
- Even though I could tell
they look graphically better.
They're not that much graphically better
that I think, "My God,
this is a fuckin' mind blowing
amount of improvement," you know?
- [Joey] Yeah.
- But Wii looks pretty bad though.
- The Wii, well,
- Yeah.
- That's because the Wii had like,
very limited hardware.
- In isn't in, isn't four AEP the Wii?
- I think so it.
- Has a native resolution of four AEP.
- Yeah, and it's a up scale.
- Yeah, it looks rough
when you go back and play it.
You're like, "Oh."
'Cause I remember as a kid
when Super Smash Bros
Melee, no Brawl came out.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- I remember, I thought, "Dude,
this is like the pinnacle."
(laughing)
- I thought that with Twilight Princess.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- [Connor] I'm like,
this is insane.
- Yeah.
- And then I looked back like a year ago
and I was like, what the fuck?
It looked like that the entire time?
I think 'cause I'm remembering
the rendered cutscenes
for that game.
- Yeah, yeah.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- And the cutscenes look amazing.
'Cause of course they fuckin' do.
- Yeah. But I think in, with,
in a case with that
generation of consoles,
like the wii, I think it
depends on the game as well,
because like Twilight
Princess still looks great.
Even though that's a Wii game,
- Was it?
- I think it still looks great.
- I haven't like it.
- Compared to brawl.
- I think every single footage
I've seen of tri princess of late
has been the HD Remaster.
- The HD remaster, but if
you look at it comparatively,
like a lot of these like HD Remasters,
I don't really see the point
of calling them HD Remasters
'cause if you put them side
by side, they're really,
unless you're like a fuckin',
you know, pixel snob,
like you're not gonna see like, you know,
when Final Fantasy 10
Remaster came out, right?
Like the HD Remaster,
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- [Connor] Yeah.
- I played it and I was like,
how does this look any
different to the PS2 version?
- Oh, did you see the,
the GTA III Remaster?
- No.
- [Connor] Oh, it was a disaster.
- Really?
- It was like the game looked worse.
(laughing)
Did you see this?
- I didn't see this.
- It was like a massive controversy.
- No, I didn't see this at all.
- They like took off the
original Grant Theft Auto
and you couldn't buy it,
the original third one.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- And they were like, "You
have to buy the remake."
They reversed it a little bit.
I can't remember exactly what they did.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- But they released this remake
and it looked worse than the original.
It was like they just turned like
the smoothness option on.
Like everything had just been smoothed.
- Right, right, right.
- So, people just looked even
weirder in the cutscenes.
- Ugh.
- And all of it looked,
have you not seen the,
- Naw.
- Okay,
let me quickly grab a
few images and show you.
I'm gonna just type in Grand Theft Auto,
GTA III Remaster images,
images, comparison.
Com par i son, okay.
Yeah, so like, look at this.
This is the original and
this is the Remasters.
- [Garnt] Oh that's, that's
- [Joey] That's gross.
- [Garnt] That's just uncanny.
- [Connor] Yeah.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- [Connor] There's also like,
there's so many where doesn't look like,
that much better.
- [Garnt] Yeah, yeah.
- [Connor] It's like,
- [Garnt] I'd say the original
has more character to it.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- Yeah, a lot of the cutscenes,
the characters just look worse.
- Yeah.
- It was really weird.
I just don't understand.
- But that's the thing with like, again,
that's the thing with
like HD Remasters, right?
Like when they see Remaster of Wind Waker,
I was like, "This legitimately
looks no different."
It still looks just as good.
- I think it does look a bit crisper.
- Ya think so?
- I'm not sure, though.
I think I,
- It's very minute, though.
- [Connor] Thank you
- I would say, right?
Like you know, compared
to like Final Fantasy VII
and final fantasy VII
Remake, by the way, right?
(laughing)
- Yeah, exactly.
- Like you know,
exactly like you that's a big job.
That's a big job.
- It's the difference
between remaking a Remaster.
- That's true.
- Right, right.
- Well, yeah, they just kind
of like uped the contrast
and smoothed it all out
and made it probably
just higher def, like,
- Yeah, higher resolution,
but like it's so stylized,
so stylized though that like
in terms of like actual
graphical updates or upgrades,
it's like, it's not something
to write home about.
- Yeah, if you look at the image,
it just looks like the edges are smoother.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- Like RCX has been turned on.
- But you're not gonna see
that big of a difference
when you're playing the game.
- It wouldn't make a difference,
- No.
- To your experience
playing the game.
- No, not at all.
- Yeah, I mean, I guess
that's talking about like
the graphical differences as well,
but in terms like gameplay differences,
I feel like the gaming industry
as a whole has just like
optimized pretty much like 90%
of everything thing they can,
that can be optimized.
And you know, every, so
often we get something like
Breath of the Wild that completely changes
the way you look at like
an open world, for example.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- And now every open
world game has a glider
for some reason.
- [Connor] Yeah.
- Even if it doesn't need it, like,
- Well yeah, I don't know,
I feel like the technology is less so
focused on making the
things very high graphics
or making the textures more advanced.
It's like, I think right
now a lot of the technology
from what I understand is focused on like
the lighting and stuff, right?
So, making it, so when you
put a character in a world
that you can add all of
the effects naturally.
So instead of having a beam of light
and you programming
light, the light is here.
It's like you program room
and then you have a
bunch of options to like
turn on the, I've forgot what the name
of the lighting thing is.
It's like lighting where,
uses like the calculations,
like figure out what would happen
if like a ball went in the way.
- Yeah.
- Right.
- From the reflection stuff.
I think that's where a lot
of the advancements are being made.
Not so much in like, the
individual like assets makeup,
because the models that we
have of characters in games
are very, very high quality.
- Oh yeah.
- They are.
They have been for a while.
- Yeah, the only thing that's left
is making how the models
interact with the world.
More realistic if they want that or,
you know, whatever they wanna do.
And so now it's about making the machines
that can do these animations
or do these things built in
and do them smoother,
from what I understand.
I could be totally wrong.
Someone might correct my comments.
- That's what I wanna know, right.
Like what's the, once we've perfected
that hypothetically what's the next step?
- Well, that's why I do look to VR,
'cause I do remember the first time
I tried Beats Saber,
and the first time I tried Superhot,
I did get that same kind of feeling
that I got playing Super Mario 64
for the first time, which is just like,
your brain has never experienced
something like this before.
And it's just fuckin' pure cocaine.
It was like, the first time I
played Superhot VR was like,
one of the funnest gaming
experiences I've ever had,
like period.
- [Joey] Absolutely.
- But like that was an hour or so.
However long time we play Superhot.
- There's no big games in VR, right?
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- They're all really good,
like one to three hours.
- Where's the next Mario's,
where's the Mario VR game, Dude?
I wanna Mario VR game, where I am Mario.
- Uses that, "Movement is limited," right?
- Movement, right.
- You, if you let like,
- Mario Kart VR, where's Mario Kart VR?
- Yeah, it could be.
I think there are a racing games in VR.
- Well they did it in Mario land.
So why can't they do it in an Oculus?
- That was not very good, though.
- That wasn't very good.
- But,
- You know what I mean?
Right? Like if we get
like a Mario Kart VR.
- I think right now the point is like
movement is really hard.
- Yeah.
- And when movement is
realistic, it's not good.
'Cause that's not what you want.
- [Joey] Right.
- But also
if you add unrealistic movement
to your character, it becomes really hard
to make it feel real, like
that thing I mentioned
where you jump around.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- You don't jump around,
you just point the stick
and press jump.
'Cause you can't do that movement.
There's no, I can't
jump in fuckin' my room.
Like an idiot, right?
I wish I could.
You know how bad ass that would be?
Jumping off the fucking walls.
- I wanna be on the
sidelines watching that.
- I wish I could.
- I will never get
bored of like the random
for every like random clips like
that sometimes get
recommended of my YouTube
of like grandmas trying VRs,
(Joey laughing)
for the first time and like
them doing like the balance beam game,
- Oh, my God.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- and just like jumping
head first into a wall.
- People jumping and shit.
Oh, my God.
- Like that guy jumping
into his TV, right?
(laughing)
That was my favorite.
- I will never get bored with it,
or like the grandma who like,
oh I think it was a grandma or grandpa
who did like the climbing one,
and they like slowly fell.
- Oh no.
- Like they fell into
like a table or something.
- Did you see those?
I know there's some places you can do it.
And it's like an activity.
They, the VR headsets that
the cables go up to the roof.
- Yeah.
- And it's like a, a
treadmill you're standing on.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Like an Omni direction,
- [Joey] Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
- And you can have a gun
and then you can like run around.
- Yeah.
- There's,
I know there's one place in Shinjuku,
I think you can do that.
- Really?
- [Joey] Yeah.
- With the treadmills?
- [Joey] I think so.
- I've done that as well.
- What the fuck?
- [Joey] Yeah.
- I know there's a few in America.
- Yeah.
- It looks really cool.
It looks really like.
- It looks really good.
- I like to try that out.
- Yeah.
- Like imagine it's one
where it's like a trampoline,
that gives you like feedback
based on how much pressure
you put on the trampoline or
something, kind of thing.
- Yeah, 'cause like,
- It's like you're on gravity
and the trampoline gets stiffer.
- Yeah.
- And if it's like less, you know,
you're on like a swamp landing,
- Yes.
- like swampy, that'd be cool.
I dunno how you do that, though.
- 'Cause like I've
heard like one technique
that people use to combat motion sickness
in VR games, right.
Is to literally.
- It's drinking vitamin C.
- Rubbing wasabi in their eyes.
- Eating a fuck ton of oranges,
pouring some salt in their wounds.
- I had to do it, I had
to do it, I had to do it.
- But also actually just like walking,
like walking in the spot, you know like,
like just literally, like
just moving your legs
to make you feel like you're walking.
And it's just weird that that just like,
that is enough,
- Rewires your brain.
- Tricks your brain
into thinking,
"Oh, okay, this is real walking, now.
I can understand this, right?
- I've never done that
before, I should try that.
- Yeah, I should try that.
- I dunno.
- Yeah, I mean like it's VR right
now is at the very new stages.
I'm very interested to see how and like,
if gaming gets to a point
where this kind of does become mainstream
and we get some like actual,
triple A games with VR games.
'Cause yeah, right now it seems like
a very overpriced piece of
tech for a lot of tech demos.
- Yeah.
- It's a shame 'cause I really like it.
I really want it to evolve,
- Um hmm.
- but I don't think it's gonna be where
I think it would be really sick
and mainstream for like
another 10 years, at least.
- I'm just waiting, man.
I want sort out line.
- Hey, 40 year old me,
I'm gonna be jamming in
VR when it's out, man.
- [Joey] Oh yeah.
- I wanna be that dad that is like,
in like doing his PC stuff
all the time, playing games.
I'm gonna be that dad for sure.
- Yeah, of course, of course.
We're gonna be the generation
when we are retired,
we're like, "Oh finally,
I can get started with my
back catalog of games." Right?
- Yeah, aren't we
getting close to the year
that Sort out Line was set now, as well?
- 2025, I think.
- Yeah, yeah, something like that.
- I mean it could be done just like.
- I don't know how I remember,
- Just like, just hook a
wire up to your like PC
or something that like electrocutes you.
If you die in the game, it's like,
(laughing)
like you actually just like
gives you like a, like.
- Like a shock collar.
- That gives you a lethal voltage,
if you die in the game.
Like we could just do, we
could probably do it now.
We just don't,
- [Joey] Yeah.
- 'cause we're scared
of what we could create.
- [Joey] I'm sure there's something.
- We're scared of
advancements in technology.
- [Ashley] 2022, for this year.
- Oh, this year.
- Actually this year,
- Sort out Line, online
is this year, let's go.
- Oh, my God. I actually you've read.
I think they're releasing, like
someone's releasing an MMO.
The first VR MMO.
- Oh, my God, it's real, it's real.
- It's real.
- We can barely make good MMOs now.
- I hope I get selected as a beater.
(laughing)
- You, are a beater Joey.
- But yeah, I hate to date the video,
but I just wanna talk about this one
that I saw on Twitter this morning.
- [Garnt] Right?
- It's old news by the time this come out.
- So probably old news by
the time this comes out,
but I just couldn't fuckin' believe it.
Snoop Dogg has joined FaZe Clan.
- What?
- I'm not even joking.
He has joined faZe Clan as FaZe Snoop.
- Okay, okay.
- What do you think about.
I might be out of touch here.
- Yeah.
- What is a FaZe Clan?
Well like I know FaZe Clan,
but I don't know FaZe Clan.
What are FaZe Clan?
- Like what is a FaZe Clan?
- Well, what?
- It's, you know, it's a,
it was originally a YouTuber organization.
- Now it's an eSport organization, right?
- Yeah, and then it, so they always had,
it was back in the day
when Card started it,
which, made it an Optic.
- Yeah, yeah.
- That's how it started.
- I followed it then,
but like they've seemed to like
just gone out of that little bubble and,
- Don't know what FaZe is anymore.
- I don't know either.
- Are they just like a YouTube house.
Or YouTube group?
- No, it's like a brand.
And you know, if you, if
you're anointed into FaZe,
- Anointed.
- Knighted into FaZe.
- You do get genuinely
get a lot of success
just off the its a very powerful brand.
- [Joey] Yeah, of course.
- With younger audiences normally.
- [Joey] Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Not a lot of people
our age watch Faze much.
- Are they still?
- 15, 16 something?
- Are they still an eSports organization?
- Yes, they do everything.
- Or are they?
It's kinda like a brand,
you know, there's,
it's kind of what they're, that's,
- Is it like an agency?
- Yeah, so it's, from what I understand,
it's more of an agency.
- [Joey] Right.
- But,
all of the eSports brands are all kind of
going that way right now.
'Cause they realize that relying
only on eSports is not
the best for business.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- 'Cause you can, you
know, if your team competes
only four times, six
times a year, you have to,
you can only monetize the sponsors
and then those events.
- Yeah.
- Whereas,
if you have an entertainer,
you can monetize every time they upload
or do something and take a cut.
- Yeah, I mean, now it just seems like
a lot of eSports organizations are
just streamer organizations.
'Cause that's,
- Pretty much.
what I feel with like with FaZe Clan now.
I'm just like, are they still
the eSports organization
or are they an entertainment?
- I always thought it was like,
I always thought it was like,
you know, kind of like factioned off.
Whereas like these,
like we have a bunch of
FaZe Clan members who
are like the eSports players
who don't go on Twitch
or YouTube or anything.
- [Connor] Yeah.
- And then we have the YouTubers
and then we have the Twitch streamers
and then, you know.
- Well a lot of the time as well,
they want to get the, the
best players in a game
or a genre because normally
the best players at any game,
if they stream, they
will have of an audience.
- Yeah.
- Not necessarily always,
but they've a lot better
chance of getting an audience.
- Right, right.
- You know,
- Yeah.
- and you can, kind of help them
and coach them through it.
- Well, they're definitely
gonna get a bigger audience now,
now that the Snoop D
O double G has joined.
- In dunno.
For some reason when I heard that,
I'm just like, that doesn't
sound surprising to me.
I dunno why, I don't know why.
I'm just like,
- Snoop does some interesting business.
- Snoop does a lot of,
- I'm sure the deal is
very good for Snoop.
- Oh, fuck yeah.
- I'm sure it's an extremely
good deal for Snoop.
- I'm sure he needs the money.
(laughing)
- Well, to me has the same energy of,
do you remember like back when, you know,
when E3 happened and you'd see
like these press conferences
and then like at every
like E3 presentation,
they'd be, they'd have this
like one random celebrity,
come on to promote their games.
(laughing)
Like, I don't know, fucking
Drake promoting Madden
or something like that.
- Yeah.
- You know what I mean?
- That it has the same
energy as that, for me it.
- It does, yeah.
- Where you just get like this random,
with this random celebrity
to promote your brand
or promote your game and
it wouldn't make any sense,
but you know, I just,
it makes sense because it's so,
it's such meme worthy,
that people are gonna
talk about it anyway.
- Oh yeah, of course.
- And Snoop Dogg has done plenty of shit.
- Oh yeah, yeah, yeah.
I mean, he's so a amazingly in touch
with like internet audiences
and just meme culture that like he's,
it's just like a win for him.
It's just, I don't know,
there's just something weird about it.
Something weird about it.
- Well he's always posting.
- We'll have to call him FaZe Snoop, now.
- He's always posting on Instagram
and stuff and all that.
Remember he like doxxed his
Uber driver or something?
- What?
- He like doxxed his like,
delivery or door dash person.
- Yeah.
- Because they didn't like,
deliver the food.
- Right.
- He like showed a picture
and their first name
to all of his followers.
- Oh, my God.
- 'Cause he was showing the interaction.
- Right.
- He was angry that he,
I think Snoop Dogg was upset
that they didn't deliver the food.
And I think Snoop was trying
to tell him where to go.
- Right.
- To deliver.
' Cause he Snoop lives in
like a gated community.
- Right.
- It's probably bit
harder to give it to him.
- Yeah. Yeah.
- And he was like
complaining on his Twitter
and showed the face
and name of the person.
And this guy got like
a lot of hate, I think.
- Jesus,
- Poor guy.
- poor guy.
- Yeah, but,
- I don't know.
It just, it, for me,
it's like really fascinating
just watching these like very
traditionalist celebrities
and like music artists and whatnot,
like kind of really dig their
heels into things like Twitch
and YouTube and stuff like that.
- [Connor] Yeah.
- You know,
like when I found out
like, you know, T-Pain,
regularly streams on Twitch
and he has like a pretty
fucking massive audience.
- T-Pain streams on Twitch?
- Yeah. T-Pain, T-Pain is
massive on Twitch, dude.
Like he's been streaming constantly.
- Right?
- Like everyone wonders,
"Oh, what happened to T-Pain?"
He's on Twitch now.
He's just streaming on
Twitch, like deadmau5 as well.
He's just streaming on Twitch.
- [Garnt] Yeah, I know deadmau5
is streaming on Twitch.
- And it's just, I don't know.
It's really bizarre that like
at least I find it very bizarre
to see these like,
people you only ever see,
- Traditionally?
- Yeah.
The people you'd only
ever see on like TV shows
and like music videos
and stuff like that.
Just suddenly being looked at.
- [Connor] You know, let me look at,
- Oh, I just dropped a $5 donation
to T-Pain the other day
on Twitch, you know?
This is weird to say out loud, I dunno.
- [Connor] T-Pain stream,
he's streamed 1500 hours.
- He's got the analytics up.
- He's, I'm looking at,
- Real streamer boy, here.
- Yeah.
- His, he's active
normally one day a week.
- One day, okay.
- And normally he seems
quite wild, I think actually.
- I'm sure he is busy doing other things.
- I'm sure he stream more than me.
- Right, right.
- He streams more than Garnt.
- Yeah, he streams more
than me, I'll tell you that.
- Oh wow yeah, he's quite active.
- Yeah.
- [Joey] Yeah.
I was surprised, I just randomly.
'Cause I remember I was just like
going through Twitch one day and you know,
like the channels issue, watch thing,
you know, came up
and on the top of it,
it just said, "T-Pain."
I was like, that can't be
the same T-Pain, right?
- That's the guy who wrote,
"Through the Fire and Flames?"
The guitarist?
- Oh, the guitarist for
DragonForce something.
- He streams on Twitch.
- The guitarist and the
drummer actually stream.
- Yeah.
- Really regularly.
- I remember they wanted
to perform their song,
but they couldn't for copyright reasons.
- Yeah, that sounds like,
- Which was like,
- sounds like the age of the internet.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- 'Cause Copyright laws are broken.
- Yeah, no, like I remember like when,
- They'll get DMCed.
- They would, they would.
- When like Gordon Ramsey replied to xQc
or something
- Oh, Yeah.
- Yeah.
- about the cooking thing,
that was so surreal.
- What a weird,
- I don't think the that's Gordon Ramsey.
I'm pretty sure that's just
someone managing his account.
But I think Gordon has very good people
in charge of his accounts.
- I don't know,
because Gordon's pretty
active on like TikTok, right?
He's pretty active on like
social media platforms.
I Feel,
- I have to doubt
that he's he's keeping up with it.
- Yeah.
- I think Gordon is a
very good team of zoomers,
- Like, yeah.
- coaching him
and telling him what to do.
'Cause again, and one of his videos,
he just kept talking about uncle Roger.
And I was like,
you obviously have someone who's like,
keeping you in touch
and telling you who's?
- Well, obviously, yeah.
We've talked about how
whoever they've hired
for like the, "Kitchen
Nightmares" titles on YouTube.
- Right, yeah.
Top 10 times the food was busing,
"Kitchen Nightmares," like that.
That was like an actual
YouTube title, like happening.
- And it worked, it worked,
it got so many fuckin' views, you know,
Even though it's like a decade
old show now or something.
I dunno.
- I tell you the people
running his accounts,
- The most cursed title.
- are like on top of that shit.
- Oh yeah.
- I don't even wanna know how much the,
"Kitchen Nightmares"
YouTube account makes.
'Cause I've noticed as well,
the YouTube, "Kitchen Nightmares" account,
literally just reposts the same
clips with different titles
and different montages all the time.
- [Joey] Really?
- They'll be like top 10
times the burger was good.
And then I'll, the next one will be like
top 10 times the food was good
and they'll just reuse the same clips.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- So they just keep making different lists
and then reusing the same clips.
'Cause it's finite.
There's only, they don't have,
- [Joey] Right.
- more than what they have now.
- [Joey] Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- It's genius, though.
- But somehow they've been daily uploading
and keep uploading stuff.
- It's genius though,
because whenever, I dunno about you guys,
but whenever a, "Kitchen Nightmares,"
- I watch it.
- Clip shows up my timeline there.
I always got time.
I all, even if I've seen this clip like
10 million times before,
- So, all right, how
busing is it actually?
I gotta find out.
- "Kitchen nightmares."
- It's about 10 times
man, the food was busing.
Oh God.
- And I think another one was like,
when the food wasn't busing,
top 10 times the food wasn't busing.
- Okay.
- Right.
- "Kitchen Nightmares" gets on average
or fluctuates from anywhere
between 30 to 70 million views a month.
- [Joey] Holy shit.
- Right, that's probably
in the range of like,
it could be anywhere
from like 100 to 200 grand a month.
- Well yeah, knowing how well
food channels do, especially,
- It's probably 200,000, 200,000 plus.
- It's probably on the higher end.
- Which is what,
which makes me wonder
why don't more reality
TV shows post as many fucking clips
as they possibly can.
- Probably because a lot of
their production team are out
of touch or maybe some copyright issues.
- Probably a mixture of things.
Also probably a lack of
faith that they'll do well.
- Yeah.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- You know, the "Kitchen Nightmares" brand
is still very strong.
- Yeah.
- Like, what show were you
thinking of specifically.
- Like pretty much any reality TV show?
I feel like,
- Like "Big Brother?"
- "Big Brother" like "90
day fiance," you know?
Like and any basically
anything made by TLC,
like fuckin' "the Bachelor,"
like shit like that.
Like I feel like reality TV
in like, especially reality TV
was meant to be watched in a group.
- Well, TLC uploads clips, all the time.
That's why they're so,
they could do so well.
'Cause they upload all the
clippable moments to YouTube.
- Well that's how "90 day
fiance" got big to begin with,
it's because the clips went viral.
- I would like, I wonder
if it would do even better
on like, if they not only
uploaded whole episodes,
but like uploaded whole
episodes, uploaded clips,
uploaded like fuckin' montages,
like with the "Kitchen nightmares" things,
because it feels like,
this kind of content is
just infinitely recyclable.
Because it's content
that you're gonna fuckin' watch
whenever you have like a lunch
and you need to sit down
and you're like, what
clip do I want to watch?
Oh, maybe I'll just watch
"Kitchen Nightmares."
Maybe I'll just watch "90 Day Fiance,"
again the same "Big Ed
Clip" or whatever, you know?
- You never get tired
of those "Big Ed Clips."
- You'll just never get
tired of that, right?
- The clip of somebody
who's over like 600 pounds.
- Yeah, yeah, or someone
with like a gross,
you know, obsession or.
- Yeah.
- Coffee enema.
- I like smelling butt holes.
Thank you.
- Was it like, what was that show?
Like my weird, my obsession, my?
- "My Strange Addiction."
- "My Strange Addiction," yeah.
The one of other coffee
enema gets me every time.
I'm just like,
there's no way someone actually does that.
And they do.
I'm like gross.
- The one thing that
makes me cringe the most
for some reason is the,
there was this one British
woman who eats concrete.
Who eats bricks.
- Oh yeah, yeah yeah.
- And it wasn't the fact that she,
- It's just better than British food.
(laughing)
- That is a British delicacy, right?
- Developing a strong
jawline with that one.
- Yeah, yeah.
- You told me, they were
like, why do Legos have,
"Do not eat" warnings
and British food doesn't?
(laughing)
- That was the argument?
- That's true.
No, it was just like the noise
that it made when she was crunching.
- Oh, God, did she,
- I can hear it.
- Have any teeth left?
- Probably filing them down slowly.
- Yeah.
- Honestly.
- Like you know that feeling
where you accidentally
get sand in your mouth
and it's just like, I don't know,
it's just the worst for?
- Like Anakin Skywalker,
like millions atrocities.
That feeling alone.
- That feeling, I understand Anakin,
- God,
- for that one moment
where you accidentally
get sand in your mouth
and you just spend the next
five minutes, just like,
oh, there's just a weird crunch in it.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- I can't get rid of it.
- I think maybe the reason
why like a lot of like,
you know, shows like
that, reality TV shows
don't post clips and full episodes.
I think it's because a lot
of their, like, I dunno,
this is just speculation,
but I'm guessing a lot
of like the producers
and the production team
and the people behind the actual show
still have some level of faith
that people still watch TV.
Like they used to back in the day.
- [Connor] Mm hm.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
And so they're like, well, I mean,
we're still getting numbers.
Maybe not as big as you
know, back in the aughts,
but you know, people still watching TV.
- I also imagine that maybe
if you're producing a lot of shows,
I imagine there has been a lot of shows
that just lost 'cause they
didn't archive them properly
or they didn't, they don't have the files
or they have them.
They just dunno what, which ones, which,
- Yeah,
- I Imagine there's a
lot of that going on,
probably copyright, you know,
like maybe the production team made it
and then sold it to a network
and maybe the network
doesn't have the rights
and the production team doesn't,
maybe they also don't have
the rights for the and,
- And I'm sure they didn't
build those contracts, you know,
with the cause of like, oh, you know,
if these go on YouTube,
then we hold all the rights.
- I'm sure they do now a
lot of networks probably do,
but I don't,
- Yeah, but like a show
from the two thousands?
Probably not.
- Yeah.
Like I notice right now,
especially like whenever
I go on my Netflix,
holy fuck they make a
lot of reality TV shows.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- Like with every single genre, right?
- But that's wrong.
- Yeah, I remember when Netflix kicking,
- It's like, pick an occupation,
there's probably a
reality show around that.
- Yeah.
- A glass blowing one,
you watched that one?
- No, no, there's a glass blowing one?
- There's a glass blowing like course
- Of course there is.
- there is like competition.
I watched that the full series.
I don't know why.
- Did they have like, the
reality TV like interviews?
- It was like "Master
Chef" with glass blowing.
- Oh my God.
- And they had like the archetypes
of the glass blowing judges.
They were like the, you know,
like the Gordon Ramsey, the an nice one,
the mean one.
- I can't believe he just
said that about my vase.
- [Connor] No.
- Is it like exactly the same format
and everything like that?
- Yeah, but like you have
now 30 minutes to make your glass.
(laughing)
It is literally like master chef,
but replaced with glass blowing.
- [Joey] Oh my God.
- It wasn't that bad.
- [Ashley] Is it called blown away?
- Yeah, blown away.
- Blown away.
- How many seasons it got now?
- [Ashley] It's got, hold on, let me see.
Probably two, two.
- Oh yeah, man.
- I remember when like Netflix was like
just shitting out like
five documentaries a day
and now they're like shitting out five
different reality TV shows.
- I not as
- Glass blowing got a season two
and "No game, no life" didn't?
like what the fucks wrong with people?
- I'm surprised that
like every single death
in the US hasn't had a
docu-series at this rate.
- Yeah, right?
- Like everything has been
covered at this point.
- Yeah, honestly.
- I just don't, it's crazy.
Like I watched one the other day
about like some grandma who was
killing people in her house.
And, and I was like how are
they finding this stuff?
Who's finding this.
This is insane.
- Why was this not televised earlier?
- I feel like I should know about this.
Grandma killing people.
This feels like a TV show plot.
- [Joey] Yeah, yeah.
- If this happens on TV
would be like unrealistic.
- Obviously you don't watch
enough True Crime documentaries
or True rime podcasts or channel.
- Well it's just,
- The True Crime podcast.
Like been there, done that.
- I've been there, done that.
- Because I feel like there's,
- This basic.
- the obsession.
Sometimes you're watching True Crime.
You're like, and then you
just get this moment of like
your, your consciousness going,
"Don't you think it's weird
that you're watching stories
about people being murdered
and just shoving cameras in
their face and in
interrogating people to tell us
how they felt 20 years ago
when their family member died?"
Like, do you not get
that when you watch it?
- Yeah, definitely.
- I feel like I get these
moments, I'll watch a full series.
I won't get it.
Every now and then I'll
just watch a series.
And it's always with the family interviews
where it kind of
makes me think, why are they just
making these family members just like
fucking talk about this
shit and cry on camera.
- Yeah.
- They're like, 'I loved him and stuff."
and it's like, it's genuine, right?
- Yeah.
- And I feel like these poor people
who like didn't ever wanna
talk about this again,
have just been shoved with it.
'Cause they probably,
when someone was like,
"Here's 10 grand talk
about your dead cousin."
- Yeah.
- And how they were close to you
and how it was suspicious that
that one guy who never
got caught was suspicious.
- You know, that brutal Myrtle,
but you saw in front of your eyes,
recall that word for word.
- And it's just the same formula as well.
I don't know.
It feels like we've turned
it into a sort of like,
- [Joey] Glorification?
- Yeah, we've glorified
murder and stuff and,
- Yeah, that's scary isn't it?
- I feel like, because Sydney,
I've talked about this before,
but Sydney listens to a lot.
- I know, I know.
- a lot of like,
she loves it.
True Crime videos, True Crime podcast,
whenever like she's doing her make-up
and stuff like that.
And like every so, every.
- The time he discombobulated him.
- Her arms were cut off.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Her legs were cut off.
- And every so often I'd be like,
and then David trapped Sally
in her basement for two weeks
and brutally (beep) her before
(beep) her (beep) and her.
But before I get to next point,
I'd like to bring up my sponsor
for today's video, NordVPN.
(laughing)
And I'm just like, "Bra,
what is this right now?"
- Okay, like I get it.
Like, you know, like the, you know, Nexpo.
- You don't wanna end
up like Sally, right?
You should get NordVPN.
- I dunno if these guys, like,
I don't even know if Nexpo
or I know rainbow has sponsors and stuff.
Like it's totally, I understand.
Like I get it.
- Yeah, yeah.
- But you have to admit
like, it is a little jarring.
- It is, it's so jarring
when I just about this like story.
- I love the channels, by the
way, I love your guys' video.
- Brilliant channel.
- But there's but there's right
and wrong places to put it.
- I dunno, it's so weird.
I don't think there's ever like a,
- Unfortunately the topic I think
just doesn't lend well.
- Yeah.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- It just doesn't lend well,
but like there's been weird transitions.
I mean, we've done very,
many weird transitions in,
I'm sure, in our careers,
we've like just
transitioning to a sponsored
that we've had for this video.
- We had the, the Berserk
thing one time, right?
We were talking about the passing of?
- Mira.
- Oh yeah.
- And because the way that we recorded it,
there was an ad break that was put
right in the middle of us talking about,
- Not our finest work.
- Yeah, not our finest,
- There is 'cause of how
we should have caught it.
- unplanned and something
that we looked over,
- Yeah.
- But there's, yeah.
It's not any like True
Crime, True Crime YouTubers,
there, I dunno,
I don't think it is there is a right way
to transition from some of
the stuff they talk about
to an advertisement.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- Every time I hear it, it's just like,
it just takes me out for a second.
- It's just like, we've, I don't know.
In a way I, it's totally fine.
And I don't think it's like bad.
I'm not condemning in any,
- No, I'm not condemning it.
- I like, I like the content.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- But like, you have to admit,
sometimes you're watching
it and you're like,
it is strange how we've
turned this into like,
it's like the common day watch mojo.
- Yeah.
- Like we've turned in,
like the we've turned
murders into what we,
like top tens used to fill,
(laughing)
like, whereas top 10 used to fill
that I'll just put
anything on kind of thing.
- Yeah.
- We just like murder and horrible acts.
Just let it fill the void somehow.
Like there's a like channels and I'm.
- I'm surprised watch a murder
hasn't gone into that yet.
There's like top 10,
like girls who've been
trapped in dungeons.
- There's probably is some.
- Probably.
- I know that there's people
who do their make-up and
talk about True Crime.
That's a common.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah,
I've seen that a lot, yeah.
- Which is also a strange
evolution, but impressive.
- It's like, get ready with me
while I talk about this horrible murder.
- It's,
- It's a cool evolution.
- It's like next level mukbang, right?
(laughing)
They're just, they're doing makeup
and they're talking about True Crime.
- I wanna see a mukbang
where they talk about True Crime
as they're like, just demolishing a,
- I hear you're saying this,
I bet it already exist.
- It probably exists.
- Don't give Nikocado Avocado
anymore ideas, man, don't,
- Bro, come on, Nikocado is
publishing a live True Crime.
Whatever he's doing to his
body is True fucking Crime.
- That's a True Crime
documentary to happen.
- That's True Crime what he's doing
to his digestive system, Jesus Christ.
Yeah, I mean, again like
I watch a lot of it.
I consume a lot of it,
but I do just get those
moments where I'm like.
- Yeah, the reality hits, right?
Yeah, It is weird.
- Especially where, like I thought
about it the other day
and I'm like, I don't know anyone
in my immediate circle or relatives
or anything where somebody has had like
something really horrible
happen to them or a murder.
I don't know, do you know anyone?
Like a cousin who knows
someone who's been murdered
or something like that?
- No.
- Not when it comes to murder.
- Yeah.
- And like
this True Crime stuff
almost kind of like normalizes it
in your mind, I feel.
Like that this is a
normal thing that happens.
- I don't think,
- When in actual fact
isn't normal, at all.
- [Joey] No.
- I don't think it normalize it,
it just desensitize you to it.
- Yeah well, I mean,
it makes you think
that it is a normal thing that happens.
- Really, I've never heard of like,
I've never listened to True Crime
and thought it was a
normal thing that happened.
- Like you watch it.
These are real people, like,
- Yeah, Yeah, yeah.
- These people, these interviews,
this could be your cousin,
this could be your mom.
Like,
- I think it's the gravity
at which they address
that particular topic
where it's like, they say like,
"Oh yeah, so Tim got murdered."
Like in the same tone as like,
"So, I met up with Bob
the other day," you know?
- Yeah, it's like, I think, yeah.
The, I think the gravity
of the situation is often lost.
- Yeah.
- In the content.
- Because there's so
much content like that.
- Yeah.
- Yeah,
there's the, the content is King and the,
- Yeah.
- I'm not saying that I want to sit there
and feel traumatized every single time.
I watch something about True Crime.
I just think it's kind of interesting
and worth talking about the fact
that we don't consume it
and we don't empathize,
necessarily, always.
- Yeah.
- I mean,
it is entertainment in a sense, right?
- Right, right.
- It is entertainment.
We don't watch it to
really, how can I say this?
Really, we don't watch
it to not sympathize,
but we don't watch it.
- People don't watch these
kinds of documentaries
and cry at the end of it.
- Right.
- Is what, you know,
like they don't, they're not like,
"Oh my God, I feel so sad
for these like families,"
start shedding a tear.
- We watch it out of morbid curiosity
is what I was trying to say.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Like, there's, there's a
sense of morbidness to where,
we want to know the gross details.
- How far does morbid
curiosity go, though.
That's the question?
- That's the question.
- Well, that's when you start
getting into the weird shit, right?
- Yeah, yeah.
- And that's the part where
it's like, "Oh, okay."
- Yeah.
- To the point where it's like,
you liking True Crime documentaries,
that's nothing compared to like
some of the weirder stuff you're into.
- Sometimes I wonder like,
do I think I'm consuming
this content wrong?
'Cause I've watched some things
where it'll be like a documentary
and it'll be like, oh yeah,
like a kid got like beat up by his parents
and no one helped him.
And then the kid died and it's like,
I have to like stop for the day.
- Yeah.
- I'm like, I have to like take a,
- I have to like of just
step back and be like, fuck.
- Yeah.
- I can't do anything.
But then people will
watch like tons of these.
And I'm like, I'm wondering like,
what are they experiencing
That's different from me?
- Yeah.
- Like that makes it so
that I walk away from this
just feeling drained and exhausted.
- Yeah.
- And then like, "Ooh, next one."
- Yeah, one thing, I found really,
- I just wanna know
like, cause I'm curious.
- Yeah, one thing that I
found really interesting
is that Japan doesn't have
any programming like that.
- No, they don't, they
don't, I've noticed that.
- And and I think it's because,
- It's like taboo.
- Yeah, it is.
It is taboo to like bring it
back up and talk about it.
And especially like, you know,
I can't imagine a fuckin'
TV program being like,
"Knock, knock, Hey, your son
got murdered 10 years ago.
Can you talk about it."
- [Connor] Tell us about it.
- Like, you know, like
they wanna respect the families, right?
It's like, not saying that, you know,
all of these like True
Crime documentary makers
have no respect on the
families or whatever,
but it is scarily like, it is scary.
- It feels invasive at times.
- It does feel invasive.
- It feels very intimate.
- Yeah, and it's scary
that no one who watches that kind of
programming second guesses,
- Yeah.
- that invasiveness.
- But also I understand
maybe if somebody was,
your family was murdered,
I can also understand the opposite.
Where being able to talk about it
and express your frustration,
- [Joey] Maybe gets it off your chest?
- Yeah.
- can help you get like grief
and help you kinda get
the story out there.
And you feel like I've told my case.
I've told people what it is and,
- [Joey] And I'm sure,
- I get both sides, I do.
- And I'm sure you know,
the ones who think that, oh,
if I just talk about it on camera
and get it off my chest
and let people hear it,
would make me feel better.
Are the ones that turn into documentaries.
- Yeah.
- That's why kinda get worried with these.
Sorry, I've interrupted like
three times in a row now Garnt.
Final time, I promise, I promise.
- [Joey] Unprofessional.
- I can't even remember what I said.
Like twice, the time I had like a point
and was gone and I'm like,
oh man, I have another point.
- But gonna be like, "Connor,
let Garnt fucking speak!"
You know, that's another
thing addressed in,
I think a I few of them
here and there is like,
this is where I start to get a bit
weirded out with True Crime is when,
as the True Crime investigators online.
- [Joey] Oh, yeah.
- That go around and then start, you know,
pushing buttons and sending emails
and asking people questions
who don't wanna talk about it.
- Yeah.
- It's like,
I think people have a right,
- Mentioning keyboard warriors,
keyboard investigators.
- Amateur detectives.
- Like what was that?
Oh fuck, what was that one where that guy?
Ah, shit.
Which one was it? There was,
this guy was like the head
detective for the online.
And do you know what, have
you watched this with?
Sydney's probably
definitely fucking watched.
I gotta ask Sydney.
- You don't fuck with cats?
- No.
- That the only one I know where,
- That was actually a good one.
- Yeah, yeah.
- But there's been
another one where a guy.
- He's just like a four
chain user or something?
- I need, I don't feel
confident saying about it.
I need to go and check.
- Yeah.
- Which one
it was on Netflix,
but there's one where this
guy was basically like,
like in charge 'cause the police
weren't helping that much,
but the police have to
go through, you know,
systems and,
- [Joey] Right.
- They don't always do
the best job, obviously.
- [Joey] But they have to
go through the procedure.
- But this guy kind of like
steamrolled in and was like,
I'll help you family.
I'll be the detective.
And it was kind of weird watching
this documentary and watching this guy.
- What was the family like?
They were like, oh yes.
- They liked it.
'Cause we, because they
were vulnerable spot.
You know, this guy was selling them,
the thing that I can help, you know?
- That's not cool.
- But I think the guy genuinely
believed he could help.
I don't think it was a scam or anything.
'Cause there was no money involved.
He was like, I will help you.
But, it just felt kinda weird.
- Okay, I was about to say
if like, if he was like,
I'll help you solve the
case, give me some money.
- No, no, no, he was like an internet guy,
who's just really into True Crime.
And he was going about being
like, I will solve this.
I'll help you do it.
- Oh, okay.
- Fuck, I need to figure out what this is.
I have such a vivid image of this guy.
- I dunno, do you think that's
morally correct to do or?
- It might have been.
- I dunno, it really
depends on the situation
because was this guy diluted
or did this guy actually help out?
I dunno, what grounds, I guess what,
from what Connor has described,
what grounds did he
have to come to a family
and was like, I can
solve this crime for you.
- Did he want the clout?
(laughing)
Like, so the next time
he's on a True Crime,
he was like, "So, you might
have heard of this case.
Oh that was me."
- It's from, "Tiger King 2."
- Oh.
- Okay.
- There's this guy who was like, "Oh yeah.
I'm definitely certain that
Carol Basking killed it.
I'll help the family and stuff."
It was just weird.
It was just, like this guy's
clearly just inserting himself.
- Yeah.
- In this situation.
- He just wants to be
part of the storyline.
- It just, it was just
like, I just, just, I, yeah.
- I don't know, just leave
it up to the professionals.
- Yeah, like to me,
I think I get too invested
in True Crime stories,
which is why I've never fully
like been into True Crime.
Because like, I would hear some
of the stuff that Sydney
listens to or something.
And sometimes they like actually
play like the 911 call
that is made about this crime.
And I hear this shit and I'm like take,
I'm just like fresh out of the shower
ready for my day or something.
And I got like a kid
fucking crying on the phone,
telling like, the police that
her mother's been murdered
or something, I'm like,
- And then you immediately
feel dirty, right?
- I'm just like, "Sydney, I wanna cry now.
Can we not listen to it?"
- She's just like.
(laughing)
Uh huh.
- And we're not trying to imply
that if you do consume this stuff,
you've no empathy or,
- [Joey] No, no, no, of course not.
- No, no, no, this is just
like, I get too invested in it.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- Just wondering like why,
like why is it different?
- It's interesting.
- But like how far have you guys gotten
with like your morbid curiosities, right?
Because the internet is a wonderful,
but sometimes a terrifying place
where you can see
anything you want to see.
- [Joey] Yes.
- Right?
And I know a lot of people
and a lot of kids went through a phase
where they stumbled upon like
the darker side of the internet, right?
- Right, like, you know,
'cause I'm not even gonna
pretend to sugar coat
the fact that like, yeah,
you know, at one point
when I was in high school,
someone was like, "Do you know
of this thing called Tor?"
And I was like, "No, what's that?"
And so I downloaded it
and I was like,
oh, it's a gateway to the dark web.
And you know, I spent an
afternoon, one afternoon on tour,
you know, going through the dark web
just to see how fucked up it was
and can confirm that's some
fucked up shit on there.
- Yeah, 'cause like, for me like, I like,
- I didn't do anything, mind you.
- No, no, no.
(laughing)
- I didn't do,
- Joey incriminates
himself on, "Trash Taste."
- I didn't do anything.
I just, I saw a lot of things
that I probably shouldn't have seen.
- [Connor] Right, right.
- Yeah, like even to me,
like my, my baseline,
I could not go on.
Like, if I see a LiveLeak thing,
I'm clicking off that video.
- No, no.
- Mmm.
- I just, I just like,
I've never had that kind of part
of myself where I was morbidly curious
enough to see something
that I probably would regret seeing.
- I can live the rest of
my life not seeing this.
- I've seen the worst things on Twitter.
That's, I'll be honest you.
- There's some fucked up shit on Twitter.
- I'm, the most fucked
up videos I've ever seen
have been on Twitter.
- [Joey] Really?
- Actually, that's true.
Some really fucked up things, and I'm,
I thought you were just
like being facetious there.
I thought you were,
- No, no, genuinely.
I thought you,
I thought you were just
like, oh, I had this tweet
I saw the other day.
- Like friends, like people who I followed
and I knew they'd like retweet
and be like, "Oh, this is horrible."
This video of like some
people getting shot and stuff.
- [Joey] Yeah, yeah, yeah, I've seen that.
- What the fuck?
- Yeah.
- Why are you sharing this?
- I've actually seen that, as well.
- I thought you were being
factious, too, being like,
I saw the tweet the other day
that said that Dimas is better
than Jesus Christ.
I said, "Oh my God, horrendous."
- That too, that too, that too.
- We thought you were
taking the piss there.
- I can, I, you know, I've,
- I know exactly (indistinct),
- the pre 2010 era of the internet
where everyone loves
sharing fucked up shit.
- Yeah, of course.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
- And,
- When Reddit 50/50 was the King.
- Definitely saw the most haunting stuff
being shared on Twitter.
- Yeah.
- Twitter is very slow
to get rid of this stuff.
- Yeah, it is, it is.
- Maybe not as good as other platforms
at getting rid of it and yeah,
all the fucked up shit there man I, yeah.
- Some of it's still burned into my mind.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- I've never been on the dark web.
I don't really have an interest.
I don't,
- Weirdly enough, like the
stuff I saw on the dark web,
just like, just based on like
what you see as an image
or whatever is not as fucked up
as some of the stuff you'd
see on like Reddit or Twitter.
- Is it like second page of Google?
I'm kidding.
- No one talks about kidding.
- I'm kidding.
- No, I think it's just
like, I think it's just like,
I think the thing that's like fucked
about the dark web from my experience,
on going on it, it's just like
there's conceptually a
lot of fucked up things.
- [Connor] Yeah.
- Like when you read
into it, it's like, "Oh."
- I thought it's just people buying drugs.
(Joey sputtering)
That's like 90% of it.
- That's like the tip
- People selling Ft, right?
- The tip of the iceberg,
you know, there's but like, you know,
there's like a lot of
other stuff you'd look into
and it's like, oh, where it's like, "Okay.
I probably didn't wanna know
that that was an operation that
is currently functioning right now."
It's some were out there
in the world, you know,
the levels are fucked up.
Whereas like you go LiveLeak and Twitter,
it's like, you're immediately
exposed to something
that's like, "Oh, that's oh,
I shouldn't have seen, like,
I didn't wanna see a guy's
head explode on LiveLeak,
but I just did."
- Yeah.
- Well, it is just like,
there's one of the few times
that a video like that or pictures, like,
gone through the cracks, you know,
it's just like,
it's never not been haunting for me
in like every way, shape, form.
Like, I remember every
fucked up thing I see.
'Cause I see it once, and I'm just like,
"That is now like fucking
ingrained in my mind."
And there'll be a point
where I'm in the shower.
I have like a fuckin'
flashback to that video.
I'm like, my day is just infinitely worse.
And I'm just like,
but there's a part of me there where like,
I know this is a reality
and I know like the internet is filtered.
So,
- [Joey] Yeah.
- It is more friendly, but like,
there's a part of me where I'm just like,
I don't want to be desensitized
to this thing, you know?
- No.
- 'Cause I know I've met some
people who are just like,
you think that's baby shit.
I've seen the real shit.
I've seen the fucked up shit.
I've seen the Snuff films.
- Why, why, why?
- And I'm just like, well, to me,
like I like being sensitive
to this stuff, right?
- [Joey] Yeah.
- Because this shit is.
- It grounds me.
- Yeah, this shit grounds you.
And like the True Crime stuff as well,
to like, to me, at least like to me.
I don't want to be too
desensitized to the group,
to the True Crime stuff in case,
this happens in my real life.
And I know someone that has,
that happens to.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- I don't wanna be
desensitized to that, in my mind.
- So let's be real, like you know,
if some person comes up to you
and says like, "Oh well,
that's, that's some pussy shit.
I've seen the more fucked up stuff."
I'm like, that's not a brag.
Like why do you think you're cool?
Because you see like a
bunch of LiveLeak videos
and you're not phased by it.
- It's like, I wanna
leave, I wanna get away.
- Yeah, like that doesn't make,
that's not gonna make me be like,
"Oh my God, what an
absolute fucking Mega Chad,
this guy is for like sitting
through a bunch of LiveLeak playlists."
It's like, no, that just makes
me not want to be near you.
'Cause you're fucking weird.
- Isn't LiveLeak shut down now?
- Yes.
- Has it?
- I believe it has.
- Really, since, when?
- Dunno.
- What a good thing.
- Damn, missed out, just kidding.
- [Connor] Oh my God.
(laughing)
- So much good content lost forever.
- Yeah, no, it's horrible.
But yeah, I don't know.
It's just like, because
there was, you know,
especially during like the peak
of like Reddit 50/50, right?
- [Connor] Yeah, oh God.
- And like the mid 2010s.
Remember when that was the craze.
- Do you wanna explain
what Reddit 50/50 was?
- I, I don't, I kind of don't want to
'cause I don't want people going onto it.
- Is it still a thing?
- I don't know.
- Pretty sure it's still a thing.
- I think it's still a thing,
but Reddit 50/50 is
basically it's this Subreddit
where people post this
like, link where it's like,
it's like you have a 50/50 chance
when you click the link of
it's a really nice thing
or it's a really bad thing.
And when I say nice and bad,
I mean like really nice
and like the worst NSFL
shit you will ever see
like straight from LiveLeak.
So there's, you know,
an example would be like Reddit 50/50,
five cute puppies or
five decapitated heads.
And you won't know which one it is
until you click the link.
- Yeah, yeah.
- And in the 2010s, that was a game.
People, like kids used
to, to play, you know?
Like I remember some of
my fuckin' high school friends were like,
you know, in a Skype call
back in the day was like,
"You want do a little
bit of Reddit 50/50?"
As if they're inviting me to like
a Minecraft server, you know?
It's like, it's like, yeah you know?
It's just casual gaming, you know?
- [Connor] Oh gosh.
- And you know, poor naive
me the first time around,
I was like, what's Reddit 50/50?
Biggest mistake in my life.
I did that for five minutes.
I was like, I don't wanna
talk to you guys ever again
for letting me sit through that.
'Cause that was horrible.
And yeah, and then it became a
big thing on fuckin' YouTube.
- Yeah, which is why I
feel sorry for like the,
one of the worst jobs I could
imagine is the people who work for,
- Moderate, Reddit 50/50.
- Moderate Facebook and stuff, right?
- Yeah, yeah.
- You have to go through every
video that's been flagged.
- [Joey] Oh, yeah.
- In Facebook or in YouTube.
- There was a video I saw of like some,
- I think it, I saw,
it was a vice video I saw.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Of like, like one of these people
who had been interviewed and,
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
- And some of the shit they
had to like, go through.
- Yeah.
- Awful man,
That job seems like
the worst job on earth.
- Just like completely desensitized.
Like just hearing them talk.
They just like, yeah.
- But apparently, obviously
you'd have to like
go through a bunch of
really horrific views
and really fucked up,
really ripe opinions.
- Yeah.
- I think, I think.
- A lot of them apparently,
like a lot of them would
like get really desensitized
and become like really fucked.
The more they did this job.
- Yeah.
- I think it was
that vice documentary where
like the girl said that like,
"Oh yeah, once you
apply for this position,
you just like, immediately
like, get therapy."
- [Connor] Yeah.
- Like it just comes with the package.
- Awful, awful.
- Yeah.
It comes with the package
that there is a therapist,
maybe on site, maybe online.
I don't know, but.
- What a terrifying thought.
- [Joey] I know.
- There's a job out there
that immediately requires
you to have therapy.
- Yeah.
- Well kind of like you,
they need the like they're,
they're the fucking real heroes.
'Cause there needs to be someone out there
that makes the fuckin' internet safer
for people like us that don't wanna see
that on our timeline.
- Otherwise, you know,
what's the difference
between the normal web
and the dark web at that point, right?
Like?
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, exactly, right?
- Just exactly the same thing.
- Exactly, right?
I just hope they get
treated fuckin' fairly
and treated well and getting paid well,
- I hope they get the best,
- 'Cause that's a horrible job.
- I hope they get the best
fuckin' therapist on the planet.
- That's sad. That's
the sadder thing, right?
My God.
- If they don't have the
best fuckin' therapist
on the planet, like Jesus
Christ, I, it's not worth it.
- Yeah.
- Didn't mean to make the ending
of the podcast that morbid.
- We went through some weird topics.
I feel like I say that
every episode, though.
It's like, "What a
weird Episode that was,"
- That was a weird tangent.
(laughing)
It wasn't, you know, sometimes
you go, you tangent on,
to a happy end and
sometimes you tangent on,
in the weird and dark ends
and unfortunately or not,
that was one of the podcasts
where tangents into,
- Hey man, that's the
appeal "Trash Taste."
You'll never know what
we're gonna talk about next.
- You never know.
- Sorry, we'll talk about
shit again the next week.
Just to brighten things.
- Don't talk about shit.
- Just,
- I just shit myself.
- Speaking of bright spots though,
look at these patrons.
- Look at that.
- They make us happy.
- They bring us smile to our face.
- They make me forget
about the horrible shit
I saw on the dark web.
So thank you for that.
(Garnt laughing)
- Your contribution
gives me joy, but yeah,
if you like to support the show
and all the things,
all the messed up things
we about sometimes
then go over to our patron
on patreon.com/trashtaste.
Also follow us on Twitter,
send us your memes on the subreddit
and if you enjoy our face or
if you hate our face
listen to us to on Spotify,
if you enjoy our face,
watch us on YouTube like you are now.
- Yes.
- All right, well thank you for watching.
- All right.
- Bye.
- See you next, bye.
(soft music)